GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THIS MEETING OF THE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON GAS ELECTRIC AND
TRANSPORTATION AND SAFETY AS WE
ARE UNDER THE STANDING COMMITTEE
OF THE SENATE.
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATION SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU I'M JERRY HILL AYE
CHAIR THAT SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF AND APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE TODAY AND EVERYONE ELSE
IT'S A AN INTERESTING DAY IN
THIS BUILDING THERE'S A LOT
THERE A LOT OF OMMITTEES GOING
ON AT THE SAME TIME AND TO THINK
MEMBERS MAY BE COMING IN AND OUT
AS THEY LEAVE THEIR THEIR
HEARINGS OR THEY'RE STUCK.
IN THOSE HEARINGS FOR THE REST
OF THE AFTERNOON BUT WE'VE HAD
PREVIOUS HEARINGS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THEY'VE EXAMINED SAFETY
PERFORMANCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
UTILITIES MOST RECENTLY
EXAMINING POWER LINE CAUSE FIRES.
WE'VE ALSO EXAMINED THE SAFETY
PROMOTION AND MANAGEMENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
WHO SINCE THE SAN BRUNO PIPELINE
EXPLOSION AND AFTER A CHANGE IN
LEADERSHIP?
HAS ATTEMPTED TO RETURN TO THE
SAFETY RESPONSIBILITY CENTRAL TO
THEIR MISSION STATEMENT.
TODAY WE CONVENED TO DISCUSS THE
PLACE OF SAFETY AT THE C. P. YOU
SEE AS THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
STRIKE FORCE REPORT CALLED. FOR
THE SHEEP YOU SEE TO BE REFORMED.
NOTING THAT A QUOTE
COMPREHENSIVE OVERHAUL WAS
NEEDED.
WE DISCUSSED THE PLACE OF SAFETY
BY FIRST EXAMINING THE OFFICER
SAFETY ADVOCATE.
OR AS A AND THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THE OFFICE HAVE BEEN HAS BEEN
CONDUCTING AT THE CAN BE
COMMISSION SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PRIOR -- TO AS A BE
INFORMED.
THIS OF COMMITTEE HELD A HEARING
TO EXAMINE HOW A SAFETY
INTERVENOR COULD BE SUCCESSFUL
AT THE CPUC.
TODAY'S HEARING IS A FOLLOWUP
TO THAT.
ONE BUT ALSO SEEKS TO EXAMINE
SAFETY AT THE COMMISSION
GLOBALLY.
THE AS WE WILL BE EXAMINING HOW
A SAFETY ADVOCATE HAS DEVELOPED
WITH THE CPUC I'VE I'VE ASKED --
DIRECTOR OF PARKS TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON ESSAYS DEVELOPMENT AND
PROGRESS BOTH IN PROMOTING
SAFETY IF THE UTILITY AS WELL AS
WITH WITHIN THE COMMISSION
ITSELF SO WELCOME.
ACTION THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND AND SPEND SOME TIME THIS
AFTERNOON WITH US AND LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR COMMENTS AND
I'LL HAVE OR OTHER WILL HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS.
AND WHEN YOU'RE FINISHED THANK
YOU YEAH.
I ALSO JOINED BY JOHN LABOR A
SENIOR UTILITIES ENGINEER FROM
OUR LOS ANGELES OFFICE AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE THIS SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON I'M CHRIS PARKS DIRECTOR OF
THE P. UC'S OFFICE OF THE SAFETY
ADVOCATE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS LOW
AS A I REPORT TO LEASE A MELLOW
SHINKO DIPPY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SAFETY ENFORCEMENT.
AND AT JUST TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON ESSAY AT THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
SB SIXTY TWO FROM SENATOR HILL
CREATING P. UC CODE. THREE OH
NINE DOT EIGHT ESTABLISHING OSA.
ESTABLISH THESE GOALS FOR OSA
ADVOCATE AS A PARTY OF CPUC
PROCEEDINGS AND ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERESTS OF PUBLIC UTILITIES
CUSTOMERS FOR EFFECTIVE PUBLIC
UTILITIES SAFETY MANAGEMENT.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
RECOMMEND IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
CPU SEES OWN SAFETY MANAGEMENT
POLICY AND PROCEDURES AND ITS
SAFETY CULTURE.
AND INFORM THE OFFICIAL RECORD
ON SAFETY RELATED RISK IN
APPLICABLES CPUC PROCEEDINGS AND
ASSIST THE CPUC IN ITS EFFORTS
TO HOLD PUBLIC UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR SAFE
OPERATION.
IN -- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
SAY RECOMMENDED ADVOCATED IMPOSE
PROMOTED SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS OVER A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF UTILITY PROGRAMS
INCLUDING ELECTRIC WILDFIRE GAS
PIPELINE IN GAS TORTUROUS.
WELL I SAY IS MISSION STATEMENT
IS TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
CONTINUOUS COST EFFECTIVE
IMPROVEMENT OF SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SEE PERFORMANCE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES PREVENT ACCIDENTS
INJURIES AND TO SAVE LIVES.
AS OF LAST MONTH AS AN UPDATE --
ESSAY ISNOW COMPRISED OF FOUR
SENIOR ENGINEERS AND THREE
SENIOR ANALYST WITH
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD STAFF
LOCATED HE EACH OF THE P. YOU
SEE SACRAMENTO LA AND SAN
FRANCISCO OFFICES.
IN THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE BEEN
ACTIVE IN OVER A DOZEN
PROCEEDINGS AT THE COMMISSION
AND PURPOSE DO YOU SEE THREE OH
NINE DIED EIGHT WELL I SAY
SUBMITS ITS ANNUAL REPORT
DIRECTLY TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
JANUARY OF EACH YEAR.
DESCRIBING ITS WORK.
YOU SEE THREE OH NIGHT AT EIGHT
INCLUDES A SON CLICK SEC CLIENTS.
ON THE BUDGET PREPONDERANCE.
NEW SO THAT IS PART OF THIS --
SB.
NINE ONE NINETY NINE THE BILL
THAT'S BEEN -- SUBMITTED -- WE
PROVIDED -- COPIES OF OUR
JANUARY US A MIDDLE REPORT THAT
WE US.
AND JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF ELEMENTS OUT OF THAT REPORT.
I'M ON PAGE SIX OF THE REPORT WE
DISCUSSED WHAT WE DID WITH WILD
FIRE RISK.
I'M EVEN AS THAT DEVELOPED AS
THE AS A RULE MAKING FROM SB
NINE A ONE WAS WAS BEING
DEVELOPED -- I SAY MEANT WITH
COMMISSIONERS. TO ADVOCATE THAT
THE SCOPE OF THAT INCLUDE
TRANSMISSION ELECT EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION
AND WE'RE PLEASED THAT THE
COMMISSION DID INCLUDE THAT IN
THE SCOPE AS ALSO MAYBE
TRANSMISSION INDEPENDENT
TRANSMISSION OWNERS.
AS RESPONDENTS AS PART OF THAT
PROCEEDING -- I ALSO WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT ON PAGE.
EIGHT WE WE CONDUCTED A SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ON BALK
FACILITATED. FOR COMMISSIONERS.
THAT WAS.
BASICALLY TO GET THE WORD OUT
AND TO SHARE BEST PRACTICES AND
EXPERIENCES AND UNDERSTANDINGS
FROM A NUMBER OF ENTITIES
EXPERTS FROM ACADEMIA -- AND
ALSO FROM THE UTILITIES.
AND AND FROM THE REGULATOR ON
AND I I I'LL COME BACK TO THAT
IN JUST A MOMENT BUT I ALSO
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT ON PAGE.
ELEVEN IN FOR EXAMPLE IN A RAPE
CASE WAS A GAS PIPELINE RISK.
ON THERE'S A PICTURE IN THAT OF
A CRATER FROM A OF FAILED GAS
TRANSMISSION PIPELINE
FORTUNATELY THAT WAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DESERT.
HOWEVER IT IT HIGHLIGHTS THE THE
ON GOING RISK OF OF OF OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS AGING
INSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ADVOCATED THAT PROCEEDING A
COUPLE OF THINGS OF NOTE.
WE WE RECOMMENDED IN THAT
PROCEEDING THAT.
THAT THERE THE COMMISSION
REQUIRE A STATE TO CULTURE
INVESTIGATION OF THAT UTILITY
AND WE ALSO OPPOSED A UTILITY
PROPOSED PLAN IN WHICH THEY WERE
GOING.
TO PROPOSE THAT THEY DO A
PROJECTS SUBSTITUTION IN TERMS
OF ITS -- INVESTMENT IN IN
SAFETY THEY THEY PROPOSE THAT.
THAT MAY NOT EXCEED WHAT WAS
AUTHORIZED IN IN THAT CASE THEY
WOULD SUBSTITUTE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DIDN'T --
EXCEED WHAT WAS AUTHORIZED OSA
ADVOCATED THAT THAT NOT BE A
CONSTRAINT THAT THAT THE UTILITY
MUST GO AND AND INVEST IN
WHATEVER IS NEEDED IN THE SAFETY
PROGRAMS BUT NOT UC
AUTHORIZATION HAS A LIMIT TO IN
TERMS OF THEIR SAFETY.
INVESTMENTS ON AND THEN --
FINALLY ON THE VERY LAST PAGE ON
PAGE THIRTY WE WE WE KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTING CATEGORIZE OUR ROAD
MAP IN TERMS OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT SB -- SIXTY TWO MANDATES.
FOR US IN WHICH THE ROADMAP
INCLUDES FOR EXAMPLE ON PAGE
THIRTY AT THE VERY END YOU KNOW
THE OUR OUR WORK IN TERMS OF THE
PROCEEDINGS ARE WORK.
I UTILITY SAFETY MANAGEMENT
CULTURE AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THEN OUR WORK IN TERMS OF CPU
SEE SAFETY MANAGEMENT.
AND JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF THINGS FROM THAT.
SAFETY ON BOND THAT WE HAD ON
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO WHEN
WE READ THAT IN THE IN THE CODE
IN IN THE STATUTE.
WITH A FOCUS ON SAFETY
MANAGEMENT AND SAFETY CULTURE WE
LOOK AT THAT AS WHAT BETTER
PLACE TO GO THEN TO LOOK AT
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
STANDARD.
AND THEN LOOK AND SEE HOW THOSE
COULD BE BROUGHT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY UTILITIES
ALREADY SEVERAL INDUSTRIES
REGULATIONS ARE ADOPTING SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS AND STANDARDS
TO IMPROVE SAFETY F. A. A. JUST
MADE THEM A REQUIREMENT I
BELIEVE THE LAST YEAR.
AB I HAS THE STANDARDS.
NATIONAL ENERGY BOARD ACTUALLY
HAS STANDARD FOR SAFETY
MANAGEMENT WHICH THE REGULATOR
ARTISTS TO THEM FTA HAS COME OUT
WITH THEM.
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA IN
ACCIDENTAL RELEASE PREVENTION
PROGRAM MARITIME.
AND THERE'S THE INTERNATIONAL
MARITIME ORGANIZATION I'M AND
ALSO AS PART OF THAT SAFETY ON
BOND.
WE WE ALSO DESCRIBE SOME OF THE
MAJOR ELEMENTS OF A SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM INCLUDING
LEADERSHIP SAFETY CULTURE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT RISK
MANAGEMENT OPERATIONAL CONTROL
SAFETY ASSURANCE QUALITY
ASSURANCE.
INVESTIGATED CAUSE I'M GOING TO
ALL OF THEM.
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT -- A
COUPLE OF THE SPEAKERS THERE.
WE HAD SOMEONE FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY WHO GAVE A PRESENTATION
THAT TALKED ABOUT THEIR
IMPROVEMENT IN REDUCTION IN
INCIDENT RATES AFTER THEY
IMPLEMENTED SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM IN SAFETY CULTURE.
REQUIREMENTS IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IT'S PRETTY COMPELLING.
IT WAS VERY PLEASED TO HAVE THAT
PRESENTATION BROUGHT FORWARD
ALSO WE HAD A A REGULATOR FROM
NATIONAL ENERGY BOARD WHO ALSO
IS A SAFETY CULTURE EXPERT.
WHO -- WHO DID A DISSERTATION ON
THE IMPACT OF SAFETY CULTURE ON
THE OUT PERFORMANCE OF THOSE?
THE REGULATORS SAFETY CULTURE
I'M THE OUT ON THE OUTCOME OF
PERFORMANCE OF THE OF THE
UTILITIES AT THE REGULATOR
REGULATES SO THESE ARE VERY.
CORE ISSUES WE BELIEVE IN INTO
FILLING OUR MANDATE.
AND SO I WANTED TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THOSE
THINGS FROM OUR PRESENTATION.
FROM FROM OUR OUR REPORT.
SO -- ALSO JUST TO MAKE YOU
AWARE WE WE HAVE SO WE HAVE
DRAFTED A SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM STANDARD.
WHICH WE ARE WE WHICH WE ARE
SOCIALIZING IN TERMS OF BRINGING
IT TOWARDS FOR THE COMMISSION TO
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT IT AS A
REQUIREMENT.
FOR UTILITIES I'M ALSO -- AS
PART OF THAT WE HAVE PHASES IN
THAT IN IN THAT PROPOSED
PROPOSAL FOR THE COMMISSION ONE
ALSO INCLUDES A SAFETY REPORTING
SYSTEM.
I'M AND ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT CAN
BE DONE IN TERMS OF SAFETY
CULTURE WHAT WE CAN LEARN FROM
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN
CONTRA COSTA WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE THE SAFETY CULTURE
REQUIREMENTS.
I'M IN SO WE HOPE TO HAVE THAT.
BEFORE AN AGENDA ON THE
COMMISSION IN THE NEAR TERM.
AND ACTUALLY IN JUNE OF NEXT
MONTH WE HAVE BROUGHT IN A A
TRAINER.
WHO IS GOING TO DO SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TRAIN?
THAT WE ARE THAT WE ARE GOING TO
VIDEO CONFERENCE WITH ALL OF OUR
SITES AND INVITE.
FOLKS FROM ALL OVER THE
COMMISSION TO OBTAIN IT'S NOT
ABOUT SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
OR THE REGULATOR BUT IT IS ABOUT
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
HOW THOSE ARE IMPLEMENTED FOR
UTILITIES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL STAFF TO
KIND OF GET EXPOSURE TO THIS?
AND ALSO FOR OWN BENEFIT TO
LEARN FROM THIS -- TRAINING
OURSELVES.
FROM FROM EXPERTISE THAT'S OUT
THERE.
AND TO SOCIALIZE IT SO THAT MORE
FOLKS CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT A
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND A
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
STANDARD IS AND HOW THEY'RE USED
AND WHAT ARE THE ELEMENTS OF
THAT.
SO I WANTED -- TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
AND THEN ALSO -- WE ALSO MAKE
USE OF THE SAFETY FLAG SYSTEM
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS.
SOMETIMES A PROCEEDINGS HAVE
HAVE VERY RIGID TIME LINES AND
SO WHEN WE GOT STARTED THERE WAS
A UTILITY PROCEEDING GOING ON IN
WHICH WE THE TRAIN HAD LEFT THE
STATION.
BUT WE HAD SOME CONCERNS IN THAT
SAFETY.
IN THAT IN THAT UTILITIES.
RISK SOME OF ITS REST IN THAT
AND SO WHAT WE DID IS.
WHAT WE DID IS WE SUBMITTED A
SAFETY FLAG IT WAS JUST NOT
FEASIBLE FOR US TO GET INVOLVED
IN THE PRECEDING THAT THAT TIME
AND?
OF THE PRECEDING IN TERMS OF HOW
IT WAS UNFOLDING SO WE SUBMITTED
A SAFETY FLAG SO THAT IT COULD
BE FOLLOWED UP AND THEN.
IT ACTUALLY HAD TO DO WITH
CONCERNS WE HAD ABOUT.
A HIGH RISK WHICH WOULD BE LIKE
A LARGE OIL FIELD TRANSFORMER
THAT IS IN HIGH RISE BUILDINGS
I'M NOT SO ANYWAY JUST WANTED.
TO GIVE YOU THAT JUST KINDA LIKE
HIGHLIGHTS.
AND THEN -- AND THEN ASKED --
INTENT ASK A RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTIONS OR IF ANYTHING AYE AYE
SAID PROMPTED ANYTHING I YEAH
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY IT IT DID A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND AND NO BARS.
TAKING NOTES HERE AS WELL THE OF
WE TALK ABOUT THE AND I DO HAVE
SOME.
REGULAR QUESTIONS THAT I CAN PUT
TOGETHER BUT THE A SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AS HOW HOW IS
THE HOW IS HAVE HAS BEEN
RECEIVED.
IN TERMS OF YOUR APPROACH TO TRY
AND GET THE UTILITIES LOOK AT
THAT AND THEN WE ALSO LOOK AT
HOW THE REGULATOR WOULD BE.
INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS AT SOME
POINT.
SO WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN IN
SEVERAL PROCEEDINGS AS WELL
WE'RE WE TOUCH UPON SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
IMPLEMENTATION AT A UTILITY I'M
ONE THING THAT WE LEARNED AT THE
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ON BOND
[inaudible]
FROM -- ONE OF THE SPEAKERS IS
THAT A SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT JUST HAVING A SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM IT'S HOW YOU
IMPLEMENTED SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE KEY POINTS
AND ACTUALLY SAFETY CULTURE WITH
AN OPERATOR CAN HAVE A BIG
IMPACT ON THAT IN FACT JUST
RECENTLY TALKING WITH THIS.
WE STAY IN TOUCH WITH MOST OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE PART OF THAT
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ON BOB.
WE BELIEVE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO STAY ENGAGED WITH THEM AND
AND IN JUST A ANA DOLE STORY WAS.
THAT THEIR EXPERIENCE GOING OUT
TO AN OPERATOR WHERE THEY
BELIEVE THE SAFETY CULTURE WAS
FOUR COMPARED TO ONE WHERE THEY
BELIEVE THE SAFETY CULTURE
ACTION SAFE OR JUST NOT AS GOOD.
AS ANOTHER ONE AND AND SO.
THEY SHOULD THEY THEY GAVE AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE -- LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU HAVE ON RELIEF.
HIGH PRESSURE RELIEF VALVES ARE
BEING LOOKED AT HOW ONE WHEN
UTILITY MAY OPERATE DIFFERENT
THAN ANOTHER.
I'M SO IT'S IT WAS THE MESSAGE
THE MESSAGE I TOOK AWAY FROM
THAT IS THE SAFETY CULTURE.
OF AN OPERATOR IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND HOW WELL A SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM ACTUALLY GETS TO ACTIVELY
IMPLEMENTED.
SO -- SO IN IN SOCIALIZING THIS
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM CONCEPT
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS WILL BE THE SAFETY
CULTURE WILL BE CORD TO HOW IT
HOW IT GETS.
SO IN SOME CASES A UTILITY MAY
COME BACK AND SAY OH WE HAVE A
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST HAVING A
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM IT'S
HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED -- I DON'T
KNOW IF I GOT THERE YOU KNOW I
DID THAT THAT'S VERY TRUE AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE THE YOU
KNOW IF YOU.
THE THE REPORT THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER FOR THE HEARING TODAY
IF THE IT RAISES SOME CRITIQUES
THAT THE I THINK.
CRITICISMS OF OF THE SYSTEM
TODAY BUT I AT YOU DON'T WANNA
CLARIFY THOSE ARE MORE PROCESS
PRETTY TO ME THAT SHE'S BEEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT I THINK YOU'RE
FACING.
IN THE LARGER ECHO THE CONCERNS
THAT WE RAISED DURING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING WE HAD IN.
OF ON SAFETY INTERVENOR IS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHERE WE DISCUSS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WILL BE
QUESTIONED.
QUESTION REALLY WHETHER THE CQC
WAS SETTING UP THE NEW OFFICE
FAILURE OF THAT IT WAS.
THERE WERE OPPORTUNITIES THERE
BUT YOU KNOW IS IT GOING TO WORK
AT THE END OF THE DAY IN AND IT
WORKED.
I AND I DON'T THINK YOU FAILED
AT ALL SO I DON'T WANT TO GIVE
THAT IMPRESSION I THINK YOU'VE
OPERATED. FOR TWO YEARS WITH A
SMALL STAFF OF ENCOURAGING TO
SEE TE NUMBERS THAT YOU HAVE.
NOW THAT I THINK MADE ME WORK A
LITTLE BETTER BUT OF IT'S HARD
TO SUCCEED SOMETIMES IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I AND I AND I REALLY WANT WANT
TO SEE.
SEE THE EIGHT YOU KNOW THE
ESSAYS TO SUCCEED IN YOUR ANNUAL
REPORT YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF
THE PROCEEDINGS THAT OSA IS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN AND HOW DOES
YOUR OFFICE PRIORITIZE WHICH
PROCEEDINGS TO BECOME ENGAGED
WITH A TO BE.
A PARTY [inaudible]
TO SO -- WE LOOK AT WHAT WE LOOK
AT IS WE GET ON WE DO ENGAGE
WITH COMMISSIONERS.
AND WE WE DO LISTEN TO THEM IN
TERMS OF OF OF THEIR PRIORITIES.
WE ALSO LOOK AT THE STANDARD
THAT WE HAVE.
AND SO WE HAVE A SO WE I
DESCRIBE THOSE THREE LARGE
CATEGORIES THEY'RE PRETTY BROAD.
AND AND ALSO BELIEVE THEY'RE
VERY VERY I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE
THEY'RE VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND SO -- OF WHAT WE DO IS WE
TRIED.
TO RESPOND TO EACH ONE IN IN THE
MOST EFFICIENT WAY WEEK.
WHAT WE WITH THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE?
WITH AS WE GROW AND IF WE'RE
ABLE -- TO BUILD OUR RESOURCES
OVER TIME I THINK WE WOULD
BROADEN AND DEEPEN THE DEPTH
THAT WE WOULD GO INTO EACH OF
THESE THREE AREAS.
SO I BELIEVE THAT -- IN TERMS OF
FOR EXAMPLE THAT COULD
COMMISSIONS ON SAFETY CULTURE
SAFETY MANAGEMENT.
WE DO CONTRIBUTE FOR EXAMPLE TO
LOOKING AT ARMS THIS STRATEGIC
DIRECTIVE -- TO I'M AND THE
COMMISSION HAS COME OUT WITH A
NEW ONE A NEW REVISION IN
FEBRUARY.
AND I SAY WILL JOIN WITH THE S.
C. D. ON THURSDAY COMMISSIONER
COMMITTEE THAT WILL BE JUST --
SCHEDULED TO DISCUSS STRATEGIC
DIRECTIVE ODE.
TO I'M ON AT THE END OF THIS
MONTH.
AND SO WE WILL [inaudible]
PARTICIPATE.
THIS COMMISSION SAFETY CULTURE
SAFETY MANAGEMENT.
WE DO WISH TO DEVOTE MORE
RESOURCES AND TIME TOWARDS
[inaudible]
LOADING.
IF WE ASK UTILITIES TO DO A
SAFETY CULTURE ASSESSMENT.
WHAT CAN WE DO AS A COMMISSION
O DO OUR OWN SAFETY CULTURE
ASSESSMENT AND TO LOOK AT OUR
OWN SELVES IN TERMS OF OUR OWN
SAFETY MANAGEMENT?
I BELIEVE THAT WE YOU KNOW THE
COMMISSION IS CONTINUING TO
DEVELOP ITS STRATEGIC DIRECTOR --
IN IN SAFETY AND WE WISH TO BE
PART OF THAT AND AS WE GROWING
GET MORE RESOURCES I BELIEVE.
WE WE WILL BE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
MORE IN THAT AREA I BELIEVE WE
DO WANT TO CONTRIBUTE MORE IN
THAT AREA.
I ALSO BELIEVE IN PROCEEDINGS.
WE WE CANNOT TAKE ON THE THE
LARGE DAMAGE OF PROGRAMS ARE IN
A PROCEEDING FOR EXAMPLE A RATE
CASE SO AS I DESCRIBED THAT ONE
CASE WHERE THERE WAS A I FIND
FAILURE.
WE LOOK AT THIS ONE SPECIFIC
ELEMENT WHICH TALKED ABOUT HOW
THEY DO THIS MECHANISM FOR
PROJECTS SUBSTITUTION.
AND WE KEYED IN ON THAT AND MADE
A RECOMMENDATION SO THAT'S HOW
WE GOT INVOLVED IN THAT
PROCEEDINGS WHO ARE YOUR IS YOUR
PRIVATIZATION BASED ON THE THE
THE IN YOUR ENGAGEMENT
PROPORTIONAL TO THE STAFF THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN TO THE LIMITATIONS
THAT YOU HAVE WITHIN -- ESSAY.
YES YES IT IS IT IS YOU DO MORE
IF YOU HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY.
ABSOLUTELY YOU SEE A GREATER
NEED FOR MORE YES WE SEE A GREAT
I I SEE A GREATER NEED FOR MORE
ABSOLUTELY US -- THE THE OTHER
OTHER FACTORS BESIDES STAFF THAT
WOULD PRECLUDE YOU FROM DOING
MORE OR THE ABILITY AND THE
OTHER RESOURCES THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE OTHER OTHER THINGS THAT
COULD IMPEDE YOU FROM.
I'M DOING MORE WITH WOULD.
HAVE TO HAPPEN.
TO ENCOURAGE MORE ACTIVITY OR IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT.
IT WOULD OTHER THAN RESOURCE
[inaudible]
I'M.
I BELIEVE THAT -- I BELIEVE THAT
THE I I BELIEVE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WHERE ONE
DIVISION AS PART OF A LARGE
COMMISSION.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
AS IT AS A WHOLE COULD BENEFIT
FROM GREATER RESOURCES BECAUSE
EVEN AS WE ARRANGE FOR EXAMPLE
THIS TRAINING COMING UP IN JUNE.
I MEAN THERE ARE THERE ARE
RESOURCES THAT COULD BENEFIT
LIKE YOU KNOW THAT TAKES GETTING%
A CONTRACT.
THERE'S A LOT OF ELEMENTS THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS WHICH IS I
THINK COULD BENEFIT FROM GREATER
RESOURCES.
AND I'LL JUST.
REFERENCE THERE WAS A THERE WAS
A RADIO PROGRAM ON IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN JANUARY WHERE THEY
BROUGHT TOGETHER DOCTOR BORN
STEEN.
FORMER COMMISSIONER WITH SAND OF
ALL IN A IN A IN A LOCAL
SUPERVISOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE MESSAGE THAT IT WOULD
AYE AYE PERSON CLOSER ABOUT LIKE
THIS COMMISSION.
IS MASSIVELY UNDER RESOURCE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I I DO BELIEVE THAT NOT ONLY
COULD -- ESSAY BUT I BELIEVE THE
WHOLE COMMISSION COULD REALLY
BENEFIT FROM HAVING A LOT MORE
RESOURCES GIVEN THE I WOULD
AGREE I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE.
YOU'RE OUT GUNS IS OPPORTUNITY
THIS STUFF THERE.
YOU KNOW FOR THIS THOSE
PROCEEDINGS THAT YOU DON'T.
DID YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
BECAUSE A RESOURCES ADVOCATE FOR
BE PARTICIPATING IN.
HOW DO THE COMMISSIONERS OR THE
L. JAY'S RECEIVE ANY SAFETY
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
ISSUES THAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH
IS THAT?
NOW GO ON MENTIONED AROUND
DISCUSSED.
SO I I THINK.
I THINK THEY'RE VERY.
VERY -- CONCERNED ABOUT SAFETY --
I THINK THAT I'M.
IT'S IT'S TIME.
I I THINK A AND WE'RE PLEASE FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE.
YOU KNOW IN SOME OF THE
PRECEDING SOME OF THE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE MADE
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED AND
IMPLEMENTED INTO DECISIONS WHERE.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED ABOUT THAT
I'M AND AND SOME OF THE
PROCEEDINGS THEY THEY REMAIN TO
BE SEEN BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
PROCEEDINGS AT SUCH A TIME
WHAT'S LONG TIME LINE.
WE'RE ONE VOICE WE WE DEFINITELY
HAVE OUR POSITION AND A AND WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS.
IS BEST BUT I KNOW THAT ANY
DECISION MAKERS GOING TO HAVE TO
WAY.
YOU KNOW INPUT FROM FROM ALL
PARTIES BUT I AM I I DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS -- THERE IS
INTEREST YOU KNOW THERE'S
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF INTEREST
ON SAFETY I THINK A LOT OF P. A
LOT OF DIFFERENT.
NO MATTER WHAT VENUE WHERE WE'RE
TALKING AND I THINK THAT
EVERYONE HAS HAS.
HAS PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF WHERE
CAN WE BE MOST EFFECTIVE AND SO
WE FEEL LIKE WE GET THE BEST.
I FEEL LIKE WE DO OUR BEST WHEN
WE TAKE THE INPUT FROM THE MOST.
FROM THE MOST PEOPLE SO THAT WE
GET WHERE WE'RE NOT JUST.
OPERATING IN A VACUUM WE WE
ANNEX WE ENGAGE WITH THE WITH
THE OTHER SAFETY STAFF AT THE
COMMISSION WE GO OUT AND REACH
OUT TO COMMISSIONERS.
TO MEET WITH THEM AND AND THEN
WE MEET WITH.
SOME EXIT THESE OUTSIDE EXPERTS
AND AND ASK THEM FOR THEIR INPUT
SO THAT WE CAN.
PRODUCE THE BEST GIVEN THE BEST
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN OF PAINT.
IN THAT IS HELPFUL IN.
IF YOU KNOW THE JUST THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN SAFETY MANAGEMENT
AND AND AS YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
IN MENTIONED EARLIER AT THE CPUC.
AS IN ALL THE UTILITIES HOW HOW
HAS IN HAVE.
YOU MENTIONED SOME OF THE THE
FOUR PILLARS OF THE SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS AND HOW HAS
THE OF DOES IT BEEN INCORPORATED
AT ALL IN THE CPUC SAFETY
POLICIES THAT THEY HAVE.
THERE BEEN ANY.
ANY WORK IN IN THAT AND AND I
ENJOYED READING THROUGH THOSE IN
THE THE PACKETS OF INFORMATION
WAS PROVIDED AT THE END OF THE
THOSE.
THE SPORT COLORS OF A SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SMS AS HAS IT BEEN.
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT IT'S BEEN
WORKING WITH UTILITIES.
MAYBE NOT AS MUCH WITH THE UC
ITSELF.
HAS THERE BEEN SOME EFFORTS IN
THAT REGARD.
YEAH SO I'M IN THE MOST RECENT
STRATEGIC DIRECTIVE THAT THAT
THE COMMISSIONERS ADOPTED IN
THEIR COMMISSIONER COMMITTEE
MEANS.
THEY'VE THEY'VE [inaudible]
THEY'VE.
STEVE HIGHLIGHTED I'M.
THE FOR KIND OF REORGANIZE ST
STRATEGIC DIRECTIVE OF TWO I'M
AND AND SO NOW IT IT.
IS BROKEN DOWN INTO.
OBJECTIVES FOR THE UTILITIES AND
OBJECTIVES FOR THE COMMISSION IS
VERY IS VERY BRIEF IT'S VERY
SHORT ANSWER LIKE THE
OVERARCHING VISION IS HOW I
WOULD INTERPRET IT.
I'M AND I THINK THAT ON I THINK
THAT THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES. TO
FOR AN AND THEY I THINK THE
STRATEGIC DIRECTORS ARE ARE THE
STRATEGIC DIRECTORS FOR STAFF SO
WHEN WE GO BEFORE THE
COMMISSIONERS AT THE END OF THE
MONTH.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ASKING US
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO IMPLEMENT
OUR STRATEGIC DIRECTORS AND
THEY'RE GONNA ASK US METRICS ON
HOW WE'RE SHOWING THAT WE ARE.
ACCOMPLISHING WHAT THEY'RE WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SO I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE COMMISSIONERS LOOKING
TO STAFF INCLUDING -- ESSAY WILL
BE PART OF THE ESPY -- TO I'M
AND AND THEY'LL THEY'LL THEY'LL
BE I IMAGINE THEY'LL BE TOUGH
HONEST TO OUR OWN ROLE I THINK
THAT IS THAT.
WE HAVEN'T MEASURED UP TO WHERE
I THINK WE NEED TO BE YOU KNOW
FROM FROM OUR OWN LITTLE.
AND I THINK THAT.
THEY WOULD PROBABLY WILL
PROBABLY ASK US TO DO MORE.
AND SO.
AND I THINK THAT THE BROAD
VISION IS IS IN THE STRATEGIC
DIRECTIVE I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DRILL DOWN INTO
THAT AND TO BRING IT DOWN IT'S A
MORE.
PHYSICAL CONCRETE SORT OF LIKE
MECHANISMS AND PROGRAMS THAT THE
COMMISSION AND THEN.
FURTHER CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE SO
I THINK THAT IN FACT IN RESPONSE
TO THIS BILL -- SB ONE NINETY
NINE FIRST TIME I REALLY EVER
SAT DOWN WITH THE INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR.
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHERE WE CAN THEN DO
FOLLOW UP SO IF THEY'RE THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES -- TO
IDENTIFIED FOR IMPROVEMENT IN
THE COMMISSION'S OWN SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SAFETY CULTURE.
I THINK THAT IN WORKING WITH THE
INDEPENDENT AUDITOR.
THAT LEVERAGES ANOTHER RESOURCE --
TO KIND OF CLOSE THE LOOP ON
THINGS SO AND THINGS COME UP AND
THEY CAN THEN BE.
ADDRESSED -- IN A METHODICAL WAY.
YOU MENTIONED SAFETY MANAGEMENT
STANDARD CHILDREN IN THE TRUCK
ARE YOU REFERRING TO WHAT DO YOU
ACTUALLY MEAN BY THAT IS THAT
THE SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS OF
THE FOR COLORS THE WE TALKED
ABOUT OTHER EXAMPLES OF THAT.
AND HOW WOULD APPLY TO THE CPU
TODAY SURE SO FOR EXAMPLE FAA
USES FOR LIKE THAT FOUR PILLAR
APPROACH IN IN THEIR BROAD ON
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN IN IN THE GAS PIPELINE
ONE FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
SOMETHING LIKE TEN ELEMENTS I
THINK AND THEY BREAK IT DOWN
INTO A LEADERSHIP STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT.
MANAGEMENT OF CHANGE RISK
MANAGEMENT OPERATIONAL CONTROLS
THAT SORT OF THING.
AS AS A BACKGROUND FROM AN
ENGINEER.
I I I GET MORE BENEFIT OUT OF
HAVING THINGS MORE CONCRETE MORE
SORT OF LIKE BROKEN DOWN SO I
THINK THAT. FOR UTILITIES IN
PARTICULAR WITH THAT A GAS
PIPELINE STANDARD THERE'S A LOT
OF VALUE IN HAVING IT BROKEN
DOWN TO THE ELEMENTS AND THEN
SOME I CAN GO IN AND ASSESS EACH
ELEMENT.
I DON'TTHINK WE NECESSARILY
BROKE IN OUR OWN SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM DOWN TO THAT
ELEMENT.
I THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WE CAN DO AND THAT WE
CAN ALWAYS SAY CAN.
OR THE AND THE COMMISSION.
CAN CAN GET FURTHER BENEFIT BY
DRILLING DOWN AND BRINGING THAT
DOWN INTO A DEEPER LEVEL OF
ELEMENTS THAT WAY YOU CAN LOOK
AT THE ELEMENT.
AND ASSESS THAT ELEMENT THE
PILLAR IS A LITTLE HARDER A
LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT WELL ARE
WE DO WE REALLY HAVE THAT KILLER
IN PLACE BUT IF WE TALK ABOUT
LIKE.
WHAT'S OUR STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WATER OUR PROGRAMS
AND PROCESSES TO DO THAT HOW IT
WENT HOW DO WE FOSTER SPEAK UP.
CULTURE HOW ARE WE ASSESS SCENE
IF WE HAVE THAT -- AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
WE WE IT WILL CTUALLY BE PART
OF THE SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
TRAINING MAKE IT DOWN INTO HOW
YOU IMPLEMENT THESE THANKS NOW
THAT'S FOR UTILITY.
BUT I I THINK THEY'RE VERY.
THE THE I THINK IT CROSSES OVER
TO REGULATED THERE'S GONNA BE A
CORRESPONDING SORT OF ELEMENT
THAT WOULD BE PART OF A SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
OKAY A I UNDERSTAND THE OF YOU
ALSO MENTIONED THE SAFETY FLAG
PROGRAM THAT THAT YOU HAVE IN
THE SYSTEM HI I THOUGHT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE ORDER OF OPERATIONS
HOW DOES THAT.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU?
USE THAT PARTICULAR PROCESS AND
PROCEDURE OF A SAFETY FLAG.
SO I'M JUST HIS FINGERS REALLY
QUICK THE SAFETY FLAG IS IS IS
INTENDED.
FOR BRING FORWARD ISSUES THAT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT UTILITY SOME
SOME PEOPLE CONFUSE THEM WITH A
WHISTLE BLOWER WHICH MIGHT BE IN
A UTILITY OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
OR FOLKS MIGHT.
CONFUSE IT WITH SOME OTHER
SAFETY REPORTING THAT COMES INTO
THE COMMISSION'S WEBSITE BUT THE
SAFETY FLAG AS PRIMARILY AND
IT'S ALSO NOT SOMETHING LIKE IF
THERE'S AN ISSUE THAT.
EMPLOYER BUILDING WHICH I
NORMALLY GOES TO A SEPARATE
GROUP AT THE COMMISSION THAT HAS
TO DO WITH ISSUES WITH THE
BUILDING OR SOME KIND A HAZARD
WITH THE ROOM OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BUT THE SAFETY FLAG IS INTENDED
TO BE FOR UTILITIES AND IT CAN
COME FROM ANYWHERE CAN COME FROM
BUT IN PARTICULAR A STAFF FIND
SOMETHING THAT'S OF A CONCERN.
THEY CAN RAISE IT TO BE
ADDRESSED ON WE'VE MADE USE OF
IT LIKE I MENTIONED FOR THE ON
TRANSFORMERS THAT WE SAW BEING
ADDRESSED AS A HIGH RISK ASK
EXPEDITED ISSUE WITH ONE UTILITY.
BUT WE DIDN'T SEE IT IN ANOTHER
UTILITIES -- GENERATE CASE
APPLICATION HOW DO YOU FOLLOW UP
WITH THOSE FLAG SO.
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE I WOULD
SAY WHEAT THAT'S SOMETHING WHERE.
IT IS NOW BEING RE IS NOW BEING
REVISED AND SO  THINK THAT
THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE
CAN DO A GREATER FOLLOW UP
BECAUSE I THINK THAT OUR OUR
TIME LAG ON RESPONDING TO THOSE
IS IS NOT WHERE IT SHOULD BE.
AND HOW WOULD INFLUENCE OF
PROCEEDING.
THE WHOLE THE ENTIRE FLAG SYSTEM.
SO A FIFTY FLAG DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
EMPLOYMENT TO PROCEEDING
ALTHOUGH I COULD BUT IF A SAFETY
FLAG.
RAISED AN ISSUE FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
IN OUR CASE WITH THE YOU KNOW
CONCERNED ABOUT A HIGH RISK WITH
THE LARGE AWFUL TRANCE FROM HIGH
RISE BUILDING.
IT COULD BE A PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT WE WOULD
CERTAINLY USE IF WE THEN WE'RE
IN A PROCEEDING WHERE WE COULD.
ASK OKAY WHAT IT WHAT IS THIS
UTILITY DOING ABOUT IN THE
SAFETY FLAG WE INITIATED IT HAD
TO DO WITH THE SPECIFIC.
UTILITY WHERE WE WE COULDN'T GET
INTO THE RATE CASE AT THAT TIME --
IT COULD ALSO BE USED IF THERE'S
AN ISSUE IT COULD BE LOOKED AT
IS THIS A BROAD PROBLEM ACROSS
MULTIPLE UTILITIES SHOULD WE
ADDRESS THIS IN A RULE MAKING.
SHOULD WE SHOULD WE REACH OUT
AND SEE WHETHER WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IS -- IN BEYOND FOR
EXAMPLE HOW IS FIRST -- BROUGHT
TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
COMMISSION SO I THINK IT CAN BE
USED IN A PROCEEDING AND IT'S
ALSO S. ACTUALLY IT'S ONE OF THE
METRICS NOW.
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS DONE IN
ITS NEW STRATEGIC DIRECTIVE --
TO WHERE THEY WANT TO GET.
INFORMATION ON BOTH THE INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL USE OF THE SAFETY
FLAG SO THEY WANT THE COMMISSION
IS LOOKING NOW TO GET MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT BROUGHT FOR
TO THE COMMISSIONERS.
SO YOU FIND IT SUCCESSFUL THE AT
THIS POINT THAT I I I BELIEVE
THAT WE'VE BROUGHT SOME SOME
ISSUES FORWARD I BELIEVE THAT.
IT CAN BE CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE IT.
IN THE PAST WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
SAME VIEWS THE STAFF THAT.
THAT NO ONE SHOULD KNOW AS MUCH
ABOUT THE ABOUT UTILITY
EQUIPMENT OPERATION AS THE
UTILITY OPERATORS THEMSELVES AND
NO.
ONE COULD KNOW AS MUCH -- IS
THEY KNOW.
YOU SHARE THAT VIEW POINT
[inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
SO -- A COUPLE FIGHTS ARE I I
BELIEVE UTILITIES OFTEN ARE ARE
THE EXPERTS IN CERTAIN AREAS AND
AND AND AND AND AND IN MANY
AREAS AND AND AND SO.
I BELIEVE A SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM FOR UTILITIES KINDA
LEVERAGES THAT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
A SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
REQUIRE FOR THE UTILITIES THE
NOW THE UTILITY IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT A SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE EXPERTISE THEY HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ADDRESSING ALL
THESE ISSUES.
SO RATHER THAN HAVING US GO OUT
AND FIFTY MANAGE FOR THE UTILITY
THE SAFETY YOU TO THE UTILITY
WILL DEVELOP A SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COMMISSION
IN SOME FORM TO ASSESS.
THAT SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO
WE CAN ASSESS IT.
EVEN IF WE WERE LIKE NATIONAL
ENERGY BOARD OF CANADA WE CAN
CONDUCT AUDITS ON IT WE CAN LOOK
FOR GAPS WE CAN'T BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING SURE THAT.
THEY'RE THERE IS EVERY PROCEDURE
AND PROCESS FOLLOWED BUT WE CAN
LOOK TO SEE HOW IS THIS BEING
FOLLOWED BROADLY IS IS UTILITY
DOING IT SO I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE UTILITY DID TO
DO IT.
ALSO I BELIEVE THE COMMISSION
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE BECAUSE
WE CAN FIND GAPS I MEAN WE GET
TO SEE LOTS OF UTILITIES WE SEE
A UTILITY HAS SOME PROGRAM.
ANOTHER UTILITY DOESN'T IS THAT
BECAUSE I'M PORTANT SAFETY
PROGRAM IS THAT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT PROBLEM WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT RISK.
CAN WE IDENTIFY IT AND THEN
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
UTILITY AND THEN HAVE THEM NOT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LEARNING A
LESSON ABOUT THIS DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT -- YOU KNOW THE THE
IDEA OF THE UTILITY.
IN THE NO ONE KNOWS THAT BETTER
THAN THEY KNOW IT AND WHICH IS
FINE TO DOES THAT EVER LEAVE
WITH PEOPLE OR THE THE UC
EMPLOYEES FEELING ON QUALIFIED
TO DO THE JOB OR THAT YOU HAVE
TO RELY ON THEIR ACTIONS -- YOU
MENTION THE TO AND YOU COME BACK
AND GET A REASSESS WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TO EVALUATE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
YOU FEEL QUALIFIED TO DO THAT --
BASED ON THE THE CONCEPT OF
THINKING THAT THEY ARE NO ONE
KNOWS IT BETTER THAN THEY DO ARE
KNOWN AS MUCH INFORMATION ABOUT
IT DIDN'T AND THEN THE OPERATORS.
I'D LIKE TO COME TO THAT.
ONE WAS THAT YES.
SO ON I THINK FOR THE CONFUSION
MIGHT BE IS THAT YOU KNOW OF IN
SOME REGARDS YES.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TELL AHEAD
OPERATOR HOT OPERATIONS SYSTEM.
EVERY SYSTEM OUT THERE IS
CUSTOMIZED BUT WE DEFINITELY
HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO SAY OKAY
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR STATUS SYSTEM
YOU KNOW THIS CASE SYSTEM IS.
SO TELL ME HOW IT'S DESIGNED
TELL ME HOW IT OPERATES TELL ME
IF YOU HAVE CIRCUITS OVER HERE
THAT YOU CAN SHUT DOWN REMOTELY.
SO YES DEFINITELY WE ARE
OVERSEEING WHAT THEY'RE DOING
HOW THEY'RE OPERATING IS THERE
SYSTEM VERY OLD I MEAN IS THE
ARE THEY USING. THREE PHASE
CIRCUITS THAT ARE GROUNDED THAT
ARE VERY UNSTABLE I MEAN THAT'S
A BIG CONCERN WE KNOW ABOUT THAT
NO WE CAN QUESTION THEM ABOUT
THAT.
IN THE POWER INDUSTRY IS VERY
OLD I MEAN THE TECHNOLOGY IS
VERY VERY OLD SO THERE
DEFINITELY NEEDS TO BE UPGRADES
SO THEY NEED SOMEBODY LIKE US TO
PUSH HIM. TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
SAFER THE IDEA RELIABLE THAT YOU
YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND THEIR
SYSTEM AS WELL AS THEY DO BUT
YOU CAN COME IN WITH A CRITICAL
EYE AND AND AND MAKE.
IT CAN UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKS
HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO WORK.
WELL LET ME CLARIFY THAT SO FOR
INSTANCE IF THERE THERE'S GOING
TO BE A LOT OF D. ENERGIES ASIAN
THIS NEXT YEAR THERE'SGOING TO
BE A LOT OF BLACKOUT PERIODS
DURING THE WINDY SEASON IN THE
FALL -- TO COME IN AND TELL THEM
HOW TO HOW TO ACTUALLY MANUALLY
SHUT DOWN THOSE CIRCUITS I DON'T
THINK WE GET DOWN INTO THE NUTS
AND BOLTS OF THAT THEY KNOW
THEIR SYSTEM.
HOW TO BRING THE ENERGY BACK UP
I DON'T KNOW IF THE COMMISSION
IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO TELL THEM
EXACTLY WHAT SWITCHES TO THROW
AND ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF?
BUT ON THE THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT
VIEW LEVEL.
HOW YOU YOU KNOW HOW OLD IS YOUR
SYSTEM AND HOW ARE YOU MANAGING
IT ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE SO WE NEED TO PUSH IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION? TO MAKE IT
SAFER.
LET'S IS VERY GOOD FOR THE IT
MAKES GOOD SENSE I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOUR ROLE
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD BE
DOING TO THAT LOOK AT IT IN THAT --
IN ADVANCE OF THE HAVE YOU.
IS THE OFFICE COULD KIND OF GONE
OUT OF ITS WAY. TO EDUCATE THE
COMMISSION ITSELF OF
COMMISSIONERS ON ON A SOME OF
THE VIEWS THAT YOU HAVE ON
SAFETY ISSUES AND I'M TRYING.
TO TRYING TO TO TO BRING.
THE FEW SEE TO A LEVEL OF OF
SAFETY COMPETENCE THAT THEY MAY
NOT HAVE HAD BEFORE.
ON SO -- SO.
WE HAVE ON OUR HI FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAD THETHE SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM ON BONK.
ON AND AND IN THAT WAY WE
BROUGHT IN EXPERTS TO KINDA
EDUCATE THEM ON THAT NGUYEN
WHERE PROCEEDINGS.
CERTAINLY WE WE HAVE TO MAKE A
CASE FOR WHY WE THINK THE
COMMISSION SHOULD -- SHOULD --
EXCEPT -- ESSAYS RECOMMENDATION
AND THEN WHEN WE ARE OUTSIDE OF
PROCEEDINGS -- WHEN WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
COMMISSIONERS -- THEN WE CAN FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW WITH THE SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM -- PROPOSAL
THAT WE WISH TO BRING FOR THEM
WE CAN EDUCATE THEM ABOUT
[inaudible]
OF WHY THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S WORTH DOING -- WE DO HAVE --
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE IN WITH
MORE SELF WE GET THE MARS
COMMISSIONERS ARE REALLY BUSY
ONE THING I GOT TO MENTION IS
THAT WHEN WE HAVE THE SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM ON BOND.
A COUPLE OF THE SPEAKERS WHO
SPOKE BEFORE THE COMMISSIONERS.
I TOLD ME AFTERWARDS HOW
IMPRESSED THEY WERE ACTUALLY
ABOUT THE THE LEVEL OF QUESTIONS
THAT THEY RECEIVE FROM THE
COMMISSIONERS THEY ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THAT.
IT COMPARED TO I GUESS OR
EXPERIENCE MAY BE ANOTHER
REGULATORY ONES THAT THEY
THOUGHT THAT THEY HAD SOME
REALLY.
IN NOW TARGET IN AND AND AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE QUESTIONS THAT
THEY WERE ASKED FROM THE
COMMISSIONERS.
SO -- THEY ARE IN SOME WAYS THEY
SEE.
MAYBE MORE WITH AND WE SEE
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO GO TO ALL OF THE
COMMISSION OR COMMITTEE MEETINGS
AND ALL THE COMMISSIONER --
MEETINGS THAT THEY GO -- TO AND
AND I THINK AS WE GROW AND AS WE
KIND OF ESTABLISH OURSELVES --
TO TO TO BE ABLE TO BRING
FORWARD MORE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK THE
VALUE IT I'VE AT LEAST HEARD.
A COUPLE OF TIMES FOR I THINK
THEY WOULD LIKE MORE OF ARE IN
PLACE AND WE I THINK WE WOULD.
WE WOULD.
THAT'S KIND OF ON US TO BE ABLE
TO BE ABLE TO CARVE THAT OUT TO
PROVIDE MORE OF THAT INPUT.
GOOD TO ADD ON TO THAT THE TRAIN
THAT CHRIS MENTIONED THAT'S
GONNA TAKE PLACE IN JUNE.
THAT'S FOR NOT JUST -- SAY BUT
OTHER GROUPS WITHIN THE
COMMISSION.
SO WE'RE GONNA WERE INVITING
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AND THREE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS WERE
INVITING A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
TAPE IT.
THE THE CHALLENGES IS TRUE TO
EDUCATE THE ENTIRE STAFF NOT
JUST SO SAY WHAT IS AN ASSET.
WHAT HOW DOES IT FUNCTION WHAT
IS IT WHAT IS ITS BENEFITS SO
THAT TRAINING IN JUNE IS GOING
TO BE A BIG STEP FORWARD AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE PEOPLE EVERY
SINGLE OFFICE?
WHO CAN HELP YOU KNOW IT'S PLAIN
AND YOU KNOW ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND SAY COME TO ME WHEN YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT?
OKAY I UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT AN SMS IS NOW BUT I HAVE
THESE QUESTIONS SO WE'RE
BECOMING THE EXPERTS AND WE'RE
WE'RE BRINGING IN.
EXPERT TRAINER.
AND WE WANT TO DO MORE CONTRACTS
WITH MORE EXPERTS THE WELL
THAT'S WONDERFUL I MEAN IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE.
YOU REALLY TAKING THIS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS AND IN A MOVE
THAT WITH THE DIRECTION WITH THE
FOCUS AND TRYING TO EXPAND THAT
WITH THE RESOURCES YOU HAVE AN
TO DO AS MUCH AS YOU CAN WITH
THOSE RESOURCES WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION.
AND THEN IS IT'S INVOLVED WITH
THE OTHER UTILITIES WITH THE
UTILITIES OR DEALING WITH THANK
YOU.
FOR BEING HERE TODAY FINAL
THOUGHT TO FEUD LIKE TO MAKE --
ONE YEP.
SORRY YOU DON'T NEED.
ONE YOU DON'T HAVE LOW PRECIADO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS WAS
HELPFUL AND AND IT.
IT REALLY IS IS TRYING TO IS I
SEE IT.
GOING TO FOCUS OUR ATTENTION ON
HOW SAFETY IS THIS WORKING.
IS THIS DOING MAYBE TO SOON TO
TELL.
OF BUT IS WE GET INTO THE NEXT
TO THIS CONVERSATION THE NEXT
PANEL WILL LOOK AT KIND OF THE
WAY THAT FOCUS AND ATTENTION
SHOULD BE AND IS IS THIS THE
RIGHT PLACE FOR IT AND BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE DOING.
EVERYTHING YOU CAN ADD A COUPLE
OF COURSE -- WHEN THE EARLIER IN
THE DISCUSSION WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT RESOURCES AND STAFF AND?
WE REALLY HAVE BEEN OPERATING
WITH ALMOST NO ADMIN STUFF WHICH
TAKES YOU KNOW WE'VE GT SENIOR
ENGINEERS WERE DOING CONTRACT
WORK WE'RE DOING ADMIN WORK AND
THAT'S REALLY TAKING AWAY FROM.
THE BATTLES WOULD BE FIGHTING.
SO THAT'S THAT'S BEEN A BIG
THING THIS PAST YEAR HOLDING US
BACK SO WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER
PERSON THAT WE'RE GONNA HIGHER
BUT TO EXPAND.
AND HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
SUPPORT THAT OTHER GROUPS IN THE
COMMISSION YOU KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE UNDER THEM THAT WOULD BE
TREMENDOUS.
AND THEN ALSO JUST PICK INNER
BATTLES BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH
LIMITED RESOURCES WE DO LOOK AT
EVERY PROCEEDING IN EVERY
INVESTIGATION AND EVERY RULE
MAKING GOING OKAY.
WHAT CAN WE WIN IN THIS ONE OKAY
WE OUT OF FOCUS AND THE ON THAT
ONCE WE DO REALLY?
GOOD HERE HAS VERY GOOD HERE ARE
DEFINED AS SOMETHING HOLDING YOU
BACK OR KEEPING YOU FROM KIND OF
DOING WHAT YOU WANTED OTHER THAN
THE RESOURCE ISSUE IN THE THE
MANPOWER ISSUE THE CHANGES THERE
ARE CHALLENGES WITH THAT.
WELL WE WE WE HOUSE THE BENEFIT
OF USING THE COMMISSION'S
ATTORNEYS.
WHICH WE HAVE TO HAVE ATTORNEYS
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT
FROM THE ATTORNEYS THAT WE
REALLY WERE SUPPOSED TO GET.
SO THAT THAT'S HOLDING US BACK
BECAUSE WE WE DEFINITELY NEED
THAT IT SUPPORT WITH ATTORNEYS
TO TO HELP OUR POSITION AND
DEVICES.
ALLEN PROCEEDINGS SO THAT'S BEEN
A STRUGGLE.
TO THEN I WOULD JUST I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT -- QUICKLY ON TO
THE WANT ONE SENSE IS -- I THINK
THE UTILITIES TO FOCUS THEY DO
RESPOND I THINK TO THE
COMMISSION'S FOCUS.
SO IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMISSION IS NOT FOCUSING ON IT
GETS LESS ATTENTION AND I THINK
THAT THAT CREATES.
I HAVE SOME EXAMPLES LIKE IN THE
ELECTRIC SIDE THE GAS SIDE WHERE
I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR RULE OR SOME
REQUIREMENTS FOR THAT -- AND SO
THEN IT JUST DOESN'T GET THE
ATTENTION IT DOESN'T GET THE THE
IT DOESN'T COME UP AS A PROGRAM
FOR THE UTILITY.
SO I THINK THAT WE DO PLAY AND
AND MAJOR PART IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING AND LOOKING OVER
WHAT DO YOU TELL THAT HE HAS AND
WHAT IT DOESN'T HAVE I THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT NEED THAT
THE REGULATOR HAS TO PLAY.
ON AND ON ON THE I'M.
SO -- I AND I LOST THE OTHER
SIDE INSIDE BUT ANYWAY I DO
THINK THAT IT'S AT IT IS A VERY
ALL IN IN IN TERMS OF ASSESSING
CITY MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS.
I THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOW THAT CAN
GO ABOUT HAPPEN IT CAN HAPPEN
FROM COMMISSION STAFF IT CAN
HAPPEN FROM THIRD PARTIES.
IT CAN HAPPEN FROM THIRD -- FOR
INDUSTRY CREDIT PARTIES I I
DON'T SEE THAT ANY OF THEM HAS
TO BE EXCLUSIVE OF THE OTHER IN
THE JAMES REASON MODEL OF THE
SWISS CHEESE YOU KNOW.
KIND OF SYSTEM WHERE IT MAY ISS
SOMETHING.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE MORE
LAYERS THAT YOU HAVE.
THE MORE LIKELY YOU'RE GOING TO
PREVENT AN INCIDENT SO -- I DO
THINK THAT -- TO THE TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN BE MORE BROAD
ABOUT -- ABOUT YOU KNOW LOOKING
FOR WHAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT OUR OR
OUR BRING FORWARD I THINK THE
FASTER WE'RE GOING. TO TO BRING
DOWN -- OR OR TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE INCIDENTS THAT ARE THAT
WE NAY REDUCE ANYWAY.
THAT'S WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOR AND TESTIFIED THAT IS VERY
HELPFUL AND WE'RE LEARNING NOW
IN MORE ABOUT.
HOW SUCCESSFUL YOU HAVE BEEN AND
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING TO THANK
YOU THANK YOU KNOW WELCOME
CENTER IN NOW I'D LIKE TO INVITE
UP OUR?
SECOND PANEL OF HIS REALLY HOW
TO PROMOTE UTILITY SAFETY AND
THE ELISABETTA MOTION CALL.
NICE TO SEE YOU DEPUTY DIRECTOR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SAFETY IN
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
INDUCTOR PAUL SCHULMAN CENTER
FOR CATASTROPHIC RISK MANAGEMENT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY AND THE DOCTOR CARLENE
ROBERTS FROM THE CENTER FOR
CATASTROPHIC RISK MANAGEMENT UC
BERKELEY.
WELCOME IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
AGAIN [inaudible]
MAKE YOURSELVES [inaudible]
COMFORTABLE [inaudible]
JOSH WATER.
CLEARLY THERE ARE GOOD
[inaudible] TO VERY GOOD AND
LIAM.
YOU KNOW APPROVED WE'VE LOOKED
AT THE AT THE ESSAYS WORK OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND AND WHILE
I THINK THEY'VE.
BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL AND AND
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT SAFETY AND AS
WE ARE TODAY I A WORRY.
I STILL WORRY THAT THEY'VE BEEN
STYMIED BY THE PROCESS IS THE
CPUC IN THE CHALLENGES THERE IS
ONE OF THE NEWEST OFFICES.
AT THE CPUC THEY PROVIDE A GOOD
TEST FOR MEASURING THIS THIS
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION I THINK THE
QUESTION IS DOES THE RATE CASE
MENTALITY AND YOU'VE HEARD THIS
BEFORE.
AS THE RATE CASE MENTALITY THE
CPUC DOES IT BLEED OVER TO ALL
ASPECTS OF ITS GOVERNANCE IN
SUCH A WAY THAT SAFETY IS IS
MARGINALIZED IS GONNA PUT TO THE
SIDE.
OF THOSE RATE CASES THE
GOVERNOR'S CLOAK CLEARLY STATED.
IS CLOSE CLEARLY STATED REFORM
OF THE CPUC NEEDS TO OCCUR AND
BUT WHAT REFORM IS NECESSARY.
ESPECIALLY BEYOND THE REFORM
THAT HAS ALREADY OCCURRED WE'VE
DONE THINGS OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS -- AND MADE SOME CHANGES
BUT KNOW WHAT OTHER REFORMS ARE
NECESSARY WITHIN THE CPC MANY
YEARS AGO I CONSIDERED.
WE THOUGHT ABOUT REMOVING THE
SAFETY FROM THE CPUC AND THAT
HAS BEEN A CONVERSATION AND WE
SET SET ASIDE THAT IDEA BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK WE WERE CONVINCED
THAT A NEW ENTITY WOULD BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
OR LEAD TO BETTER SAFETY
OUTCOMES -- I I'M NOW KIND OF
QUESTIONING THAT CONCLUSION.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND I
OF OF SO I'M APPRECIATE YOUR
COMING TODAY TO MAYBE WE COULD
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION A LITTLE
BIT TO SEE IF WE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
OR IF THE MODEL OF HAVING SAFETY
WITHIN THOSE RATE CASES WITHIN
THE P. YOU SEE.
A IS SOMETHING THAT -- THAT HAS
WORKED SO WE IT TO PROFESSOR
SHOWMAN AND AND ROBERT YOU'VE
BEEN RESEARCHING AND WRITING
ABOUT SAFETY FOR MANY YEARS AND
HAVE RECENTLY.
BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE C. P. U.
C. L. LYSINE ITS SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND DIRECTOR MALASHENKO EIGHT
YOU ARE AND AND HAVE BEEN -- THE
HEAD OF THE SAFETY DIVISION CPUC
AND NOW YOU'RE OVERSEEING BOTH --
ESSAY AS WELL AS THE AUDITOR'S
AND COMPLIANCE OFFICERS AT THE
COMMISSION JOURNALING YOU DON'T
DO IT THE COMMISSION.
SEEMS LIKE YOUR YOU'VE BEEN --
HAS WITH WATCHED -- OVER THE
LAST NINE YEARS YOU'RE YOU KEEP
EXPANDING.
YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES AND AND
THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD THING I
THINK THE IT IT DID WITH THE
SUCCESSES THAT YOU'VE HAD SO
THAT'S NICE -- AND ASK A MEMBER
OF THE UTILITY TO BE HERE TODAY
TO BE PART OF THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I VIEW THEM.
NO THERE REALLY AN IMPORTANT
PLAYER IN THIS DIALOGUE THAT WE
HAVE OF HOW SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS WORK AND HOW THEY COME
TOGETHER.
AND HOW THE REGULATED BUT ONE OF
THE THEMES FROM THE SAFETY
LITERATURE IS NEEDING TO HAVE
CLEAR LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
AND TRUST BETWEEN THE REGULATED
ENTITIES AND THE REGULATORS WE
WERE HOPING THAT US THE GENIE.
COULD HIGHLIGHT INSTANCES OF
WHERE THE CPUC HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN DEVELOPING THESE
CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION OR IF
THEY MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
WITHIN WITH INVITED THE OTHER
UTILITIES AS WELL BUT OF THE
UTILITIES WE SPOKE WITH -- WERE
TROUBLES AT HAVING A PUBLIC
DIALOGUE IN THE FILTER THAT
WOULD NOT BE WELL RECEIVED BY
THE REGULATOR IF THEY WERE
SITTING HERE TALKING ABOUT THAT
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE EXACT ISSUE
WE RAISE IN THE BACKGROUND
REPORT THAT THERE.
LACKS OPEN COMMUNICATION AND
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THOSE -- SAFETY
MANAGEMENT AT THE CPUC WHETHER
IT'S WITHIN THE CPUC OR AS THEY
REGULATE THE UTILITIES AND
THAT'S THAT ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIPS OR ARE SO INDEBTED
THAT EVEN CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM.
CANNOT BE COMMUNICATED AND
THAT'S WHAT WE SEE TODAY AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE EMPTY
CHAIR SIT IN THERE TODAY SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT HOPEFULLY
WE CAN HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND BRING SOMETHING FOR THAT
WILL COME FROM IT SO.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO THE OFFICIAL
ONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS OR OVERWORKED AND MAY
MAYBE WILL WILL GO TO FILL
DIRECTOR MOTION CO FIRST.
AND IT WILL COME BACK IF.
LOOK IN THE ORDER IN WHICH MY
AGENDA IS I WAS GOING LEFT TO
RIGHT SO.
WELCOME AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON.
ELM [inaudible] EIGHT THINK.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CHANGE THE
COMMISSION'S SIXTY FUNCTION OWN
IT REALLY HAS THE CHANGE QUITE
DRAMATICALLY IN MANY WAYS.
L. BUT AT THE SAME TIME HOME.
EIGHT THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
RESULTS IN THE IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND THE CHALLENGES THE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO HEALTH IN THE
STATE'S [inaudible]
L. O..
EVERYONE RECOGNIZES THAT IT'S
NOT.
ENOUGH [inaudible]
AND EITHER WHEN WE IN -- STARTS
ONE PACK THIS.
AS TO WHY [inaudible]
HELLO.
YOU DO ONE THING THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
TO REMEMBER ABOUT THESE SYSTEMS.
IS THE LENGTH OF TIME IT TAKES
FOR ANY CHANGE TO REALLY HOW
IMPACT IN THE FIELD AND THAT'S
ONE THING THAT I THINK IS VERY
DIFFERENCE.
FROM.
EITHER BETWEEN UTILITY
OPERATIONS AND LET'S SAY EVEN
LIKE AIRLINE INDUSTRY RIGHT IS
JUST AMOUNT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE HEALTH.
IN THE FIELD AND HOME THE FACT
THAT A LOT OF RESULTS THAT WE
SEE THE RESULTS OF THE STORMS
THAT ARE IN PLACE.
ELEMENT AND THEY TAKE A LONG
TIME. TO SHIFT.
THROUGH THROUGH THE YOU KNOW YOU
KIND OF OPERATING ON THESE TEN
YEAR CYCLES.
OF IN SOME CASES EVEN MORE WHEN
YOU ACTUALLY CAN SEE THE
SYSTEMIC RESULTS I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE REALLY BIG CHALLENGES.
THAT WE HELD AS WE TRY.
TO HELP IMPROVE THE SAFETY EL
PARADIGM IN CALIFORNIA.
IS.
THAT WE TEND TO JUDGE
PERFORMANCE ON THE VERY SPEED
YOU THOUGH IMMEDIATE SORT OF
SENSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING.
BUT THAT'S OT NECESSARILY A
REFLECTION ALL OF ACTIONS.
THE END OF THERE ARE ALSO TAKING
PRE PLACE FOR FROM REGULATORY
FOR POINT OF VIEW BECAUSE THERE
IS SUCH A BIG OUT TIME LAG.
AND YOU KNOW THAT IS ONE TOPIC
THAT A CD CAME OVER GET MIX THEM
ALL LAW IT ALL OF YOU KNOW WHEN
WE TALKING FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT
SEEK TO CULTURE.
IS THAT.
THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH THAT YOU
CAN DO IN TERMS OF SAFETY
CULTURE -- THAT HAS A VERY
IMMEDIATE RESULTS IN THE FIELD.
YEAR BECAUSE IN THE YOU KNOW A
GALLON CAN OF GOING BACK TO THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY IS LIKE AN
EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW WE YOU HEALTH OPERATORS
ARE FLYING YOU KNOW PILOT IS
FLYING A PLANE RIGHT AND THEY'RE
MAKING CERTAIN DECISIONS AND EAT
IF YOU SHIFT THE CULTURE YOU CAN
SORT OF ON THE SHORTER TIME
SCALE YOU KNOW SEE THE RESULTS
THAT YOU HAVE WITH THE FOR
OPERATION.
THANK YOU FOR TRYING TO IMPROVE
WORKER SAFETY ALL THAT THIS KIND
OF QUESTIONS OF CULTURE.
LANCE WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE
RATE BECAUSE THEN YOU CAN CHANGE
BEHAVIOR AND YOU CAN KIND OF
MEASURE HOW MANY IN THE INJURIES
OR INCIDENTS YOU HEALTH.
BUT WHEN WAS STARTING TO TALK
ABOUT ALL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE REPLACEMENTS AND
HOW UTILITIES RUN THEIR SYSTEMS
AND OF MEANS SEEING THEIR ASSETS.
ELEMENT EVEN IF YOU HAVE A WORK
FORCE EVE THAT.
HOUSE COMPLETE FOCUS ON SAFETY
CULTURE AND YOU HALL OF YOU KNOW
ALL ISSUES RELATED TO THAT
RESOLVED YOU WOULD STILL IT
WOULD STILL TAKE YEARS FOR
ACTUAL.
CHANGES IN THE FIELD TO TAKE
PLACE SO I THINK THAT ABOUT
SOMETHING.
ELM THAT.
EIGHT L. WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
UNPACK OF WHERE.
OR THE ISSUES IN THE IMMEDIATE
PLANS.
AND HOW DO WE CAN OVER MANAGE
THAT TENSION BETWEEN WANTING TO
SEE IMMEDIATE RESULTS IN MAKING
LONG TERM CHANGES THAT MAY NOT
ACTUALLY.
HALL OF RESULTS THAT ARE YOU
KNOW VERY MEDIA TO MEASURABLE.
IN THAT'LL BE READY TO MY
QUESTIONS WHEN WE GET THERE SO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL.
ONE THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE AND WE KNOW THAT
YOU'RE FACING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
A LOT OF REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS AND POSSIBLY SOME.
NEW RESPONSIBILITIES NOT ONLY
FOR UTILITIES AND REGULATOR BUT
FOR YOURSELVES AS AN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
SO WHAT WE THOUGHT WE WOULD DO
TO PERHAPS HELP YOUR
DELIBERATIONS IS WE WOULD LOOK
BACK OVER.
OUR EXPERIENCE IN LOOKING AT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAD TO MANAGE
HAVE HAD TO MANAGE THE HAZARDOUS
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND HAVE DONE
SO SUCCESSFULLY IN.
THOSE THAT HAVEN'T.
AND TRY TO DISTILL WHAT WE THINK
ARE SOME OF FOUNDATIONAL
FUNCTIONS.
THAT WE BELIEVE WOULD BE
NECESSARY FOR EFFECTIVE SAFETY
REGULATIONS.
I JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT A FEW
OF THEM.
AND USE THESE AS IN A SENSE
STARTING POINTS FOR A
CONVERSATION ABOUT OPTIONS.
THE FIRST ONE THAT WE FIND IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IS BELIEVE IT
OR NOT ASKING QUESTIONS.
AFTER THE DEEPWATER HORIZON --
ACCIDENT IN THE GULF OF MEXICO --
INVESTIGATION COMMITTEE WAS SET
UP HE TOOK HOLD OF THE SAFETY
HANDBOOK FOR THE DEEPWATER
HORIZON RIG WHICH WAS A MASSIVE
THING READ THROUGH WOOD COVER TO
COVER.
AND AT THE END OF IT HE SAID.
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHEN IT'S BAD
ENOUGH TO HAVE TO ACT FAST?
THERE WAS NO ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION IN THE HANDBOOK AND IN
FACT IT TURNED OUT THAT ACCIDENT
TURNED AROUND PEOPLE NOT
REALIZING WHEN IT WAS BAD ENOUGH
TO HAVE TO ACCESS.
SO SOMETIMES ASKING KEY
QUESTIONS EVEN IF EMBARRASSING I
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE LOOKED
AT THESE -- ORGANIZATIONS THAT
MANAGE THEIR SYSTEM PRETTY WELL
DOWN TO THE CONTROL ROOM FOR
EXAMPLE PEOPLE PLAY THE WHAT IF
GAME.
AND THEY WOULD STAND RUNS AROUND
AND SEE WHAT WE LOST POWER RIGHT
NOW WHEN THERE WAS AN EARTHQUAKE
BUT WE DO.
AND THAT WHAT IF GAME WAS PLAYED
CONTINUALLY.
AND THEY ARE CONSTANTLY ASKING
THEMSELVES AND WORK PLANNING
SESSIONS.
HAVE WE MISSED ANYTHING IN THIS
PLAN WHAT IF THIS ASSUMPTION
TURNS OUT TO BE WRONG.
AND THERE'S A CONSTANT
QUESTIONING IN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS -- AND THE
QUESTION OF THE QUESTIONS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN ANSWER
RIGHT AWAY THE PERSON WHO ASKS.
BUT ASKING IT IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT PARTLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE REALLY AFRAID OF MAKING
ERRORS.
ERRORS IN THE CALCULATION IN THE
ANTICIPATION IN THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THINGS.
AND ASKING QUESTIONS AS A WAY IN
WHICH THEY CAN SEE WHERE THE
UNCERTAINTIES LIE IN THEIR
OPERATIONS.
SO THAT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
FUNCTION IN A SAFETY REGULATORY
REGIME.
IT CAN BE DISTRIBUTED IN MANY
PLACES I'M THINKING THAT THIS IS
ALSO A FUNCTION THAT YOU'RE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
CAN VERY PRODUCTIVELY ASK OF
PEOPLE WHO TESTIFY FROM THE
COMMITTEES FROM THE COMMISSION
AND FROM THE UTILITIES.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR IN THE
OFFICE OF THE SAFETY ADVOCATE?
IS IT THIS IS KIND OF A
DIFFICULT THING FOR THEM TO DO
SIMPLY ASK QUESTIONSAND PART OF
IT IS BECAUSE THEY FEEL IT SEEMS
TO US.
THEY HAVE TO ADVOCATE FOR
SOMETHING.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN ACTUAL
PROPOSITION.
AND IN A SENSE IF THEY ARE
ASKING A QUESTION THEY SHOULD BE
PROVIDING AN ANSWER.
AND THIS IS OUR UNDERSTANDABLE
IN A SENSE BECAUSE THE NEW
ORGANIZATION AND THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THE A STANDING THEY HAVE
IN THE REST OF THE UP YOU SEE
AND I JUST WANTED.
USE THIS FOR THE MOMENT TO SAY
THAT FROM OUR STANDPOINT.
IT HAS BEEN A VERY ROCKY
INTRODUCTION FOR THE OS EIGHT
INTO THE CPUC -- THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE BEEN STUCK INTO AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS MANY OTHER
COMPETING MISSIONS THE SAFETY.
THAT HAS MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CONSIDER
SAFETY PART OF WHAT THEY DO.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN UNDERSTAFFED
CERTAINLY IN STAFF BUT ALSO IN
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED.
AND THE CPUC ITSELF HAS NEVER
BEEN PROPERLY [inaudible]
INTRODUCED. TO THE FUNCTIONS THE
FULL RANGE OF FUNCTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE BY AN OFFICE OF
THE SAFETY ADVOCATE QUESTION
ASKING IS ONE OF THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO HAVE THE
ANSWERS.
THEY CAN ASK QUESTIONS AND
PROCEEDING AND FORCE OTHER
PEOPLE TO THINK ABOUT ANSWERS
AND THAT IS APPROPRIATE SAFETY
ADVOCACY AS WELL.
WHAT THE CPC SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
SEEMS TO ME IS? TO HAVE HAD A
FORMAL INTRODUCTION OF THAT ROLE
FOR THAT THE ROLES FOR THAT
OFFICE SOCIALIZE THE REST OF THE
COMMISSION. TO ACCEPTING THEM
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE JUST
ANOTHER DIVISION SAFETY SHOULD
BE A PREEMINENT ISSUE FOR THE
CPUC.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO COMPETE.
FOR AGENDA SPACE WITH OTHER --
DIVISIONS AND OTHER UNITS.
AND SO ON OUR VIEW IS THAT IT'S
NOT TOO LATE BY THE WAY FOR THE
SI PC TO DO A BETTER
INTRODUCTION.
IT MIGHT BE WORTHWHILE TO
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT SAFETY
ADVOCACY FUNCTIONS AND WHAT'S
REQUIRED FOR EFFECTIVE SAFETY
REGULATION.
WITHIN THE WHOLE COMMISSION --
SO THAT'S ONE ONE ISSUE A SECOND
FOUNDATION FUNCTION IS RESEARCH
AND ANALYSIS.
THE BEST SAFETY.
REGULATORY REGIMES THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE FAA IN
THE NRC.
THEY DO THEIR OWN RESEARCH A LOT
OF IT THEY GIVE GRANTS FOR
RESEARCH THEY HAVE PEOPLE AROUND
WHO ARE EXPERTS.
IN THAT PROCESS OF RESEARCH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR NOT JUST.
KNOWING.
WHAT ISSUES ARE GOING TO
CONFRONT THEM THE RESEARCH GIVES
THEM A FORWARD LOOKING LOOK AT
THE?
STATE OF REACTIVE LOOK.
ON BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY DO.
AND MAKE REGULATORY DECISIONS
RIGHT NOW THE CPUC IS
CONSIDERING IN ONE OF ITS MAJOR
PROCEEDINGS.
OPTIONS FOR RESTRUCTURING P.
JEANNIE WITH RESPECT TO
PROMOTING ITS SAFETY CULTURE.
THAT IS A VERY DIFFICULT
QUESTION WE DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
HOW TO GROW SAFETY CULTURE IN AN
ORGANIZATION [inaudible]
CONCLUSIVELY SYSTEMATICALLY
THEY'RE ASKING THAT QUESTION SO --
BASICALLY WHATEVER THEY DECIDE
IN TERMS OF RESTRUCTURING.
IS GOING TO BE ON ON CERTAIN
PROPOSITION.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FOLLOW
VERY CAREFULLY.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF WHATEVER THEY
DECIDE IN P. JEANNIE THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE.
GOOD INSPECTIONS BUT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE MET THEY NEED THEY
NEED METRICS.
RIGHT NOW THE P. YOU SEE HAS NO.
SAFETY METRICS.
THEY DON'T REGULATE FOR SAFETY
MANAGEMENT THEY HAVE NO
ORGANIZATIONAL METRICS FOR
SAFETY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM OR FOR
SAFETY CULTURE.
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T DO A LOT OF RESEARCH.
AND BY NOT DOING THAT RESEARCH
IT SEEMS TO US.
THEY PUT THEMSELVES IN A VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION RELATIVE TO
DECISION MAKING AND FOLLOWING
THROUGH ON WHAT THEY DECIDE TO
DO.
SO OUR VIEW IS THAT RESEARCH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT -- THE ESSAY IN
OUR REGIONAL UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
COULD BE WOULD HAVE BEEN --
SAFETY ANALYSIS THE OFFICER
SAFETY ANALYSIS AND WOULD HAVE
HAD.
SAFETY EXPERTS WITH ON ON STAFF.
TO ACTUALLY DO FOR LOOKING
RESEARCH.
THIS IS WERE POSSIBLY
INDEPENDENT SAFETY REGULAR AN
INDEPENDENT UTILI SAFETY BOARD
COULD BE HELPFUL WITH EXPERTS
WHO WOULD ACTUALLY DO RESEARCH
USEFUL FOR THE PC -- SO.
IN THAT SENSE THAT'S A FUNCTION
THAT NEEDS TO BE TENDED TO AND
UNLIKE MANY OTHER SAFETY
REGULATORY ORGANIZATIONS.
IN OUR VIEW THE CPUC IS VERY.
UNDER OF ORGANIZED FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF DOING SAFETY
RESEARCH.
A THIRD ISSUE IS ACCIDENT AND
INCIDENT INVESTIGATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FUNCTION FOR ALL
SAFETY REGULATORY.
ORGANIZATIONS -- SOME USE
EXTERNAL USES THE EXTERNAL
ORGANIZATION THE FAA USES THE
NTSB.
AND ACTUALLY -- THE CPUC AFTER
THE SAN BRUNO EXPLOSION HAD
CREATED AN INDEPENDENT
DISTILLERY INVESTIGATORY PANEL
THAT REALLY DID A REALLY NICE.
REVIEW -- BUT A LOT OF THE
INCIDENT AN ACCIDENT
INVESTIGATIONS ARE DONE BY IN
HOUSE.
CPUC PEOPLE THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH THAT THEY ARE --
DIRECTED MOST OF THEM BY
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
FROM OUR UNDERSTANDING THOSE ALE
JAY'S HAVE NO TRAINING IN ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS.
NO TRAINING SAFETY MANAGEMENT NO
TRAINING SAFETY CULTURE.
SO PART OF THIS IS AGAIN WHAT DO
THEY KNOW THE RIGHT TO WRITE THE
TO ENHANCE THE RIGHT QUESTIONS
FROM THAT WE THINK THAT THAT
PROCESS COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
UPGRADED -- ANOTHER FUNCTION
INSPECTIONS AND ENFORCEMENT --
THIS IS WHERE I THINK.
A LOT OF ADVANCE AND UPGRADING
REALLY NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THE NUCLEAR REGULATORY
COMMISSION HAS TWO FULL TIME
RESIDENT INSPECTORS ON EVERY
PLANE AT EVERY PLANT IT OPERATE
IT IT OVERSEAS AND ALL OF THE
FUEL PROCESSING PLANTS THEY ARE
THERE FULL TIME.
THEY CAN GO TO ANY MEETING THEY
WISH.
TO THE P. YOU SEE HAS.
SOME CERTAINLY HAS SOME --
INSPECTORS BUT THEY PERIODICALLY
VISIT IT'S TOUGH TO KEEP TRACK
OF THE LARGE UTILITY BUT THEY
ONLY MAKE PERIODIC VISITS.
AND THEY HAVE ARE.
REALLY NO TRAINING IN THE WHAT
TO LOOK FOR FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF SAFETY MANAGEMENT OR SAFETY
CULTURE WHEN THEY GO TO DO THAN
INSPECTIONS.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT A HIGHLY
TRAINED AND PROFESSIONAL LIES.
INSPECTION STAFF COULD ENERGIZE
THE SAFETY MANAGEMENT AND
REGULATORY APPROACH OF THE
ENTIRE AGENCY AND THAT'S
SOMETHING TO TO REALLY CONSIDER.
ONE OF THE THINGS IN OUR VIEW
THAT CAUSES SOME PROBLEMS IS
[inaudible]
A WE SAW THIS IN OUR VISIT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A A AN
UNUSUAL -- DIVISION THAT IS NOT
EVEN EQUALLY UNDERSTOOD BY
EVERYBODYBETWEEN ADVICE AND
ADVOCACY AND BETWEEN POLICY AND
ENFORCEMENT.
SUBTOTAL OF THESE DIVISIONS.
MAKE MOST INSPECTORS THAT WE
TALKED TO BELIEVE IT'S NOT THEIR
ROLE. TO GIVE ADVICE ON POLICY.
AND IT WOULDN'T BE BECAUSE IT'S
NOT APPROPRIATE FOR ENFORCERS.
TO MAKE THE LAWS THAT THEY IN
FORCE.
WELL THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WE
BELIEVE IS REALLY USEFUL AND IN
FACT BY DOING THAT.
THEY DENY POLICY THE PEOPLE AT
THE POLICY LEVEL A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THEIR
SEED.
IN THESE UTILITIES.
AND WHAT REGULATIONS ARE WORKING
WELL FROM THEIR STANDPOINT
ENTERS A COMPLIANCE
INEFFECTIVENESS AND WHICH ONES.
ARE NOT AND WHAT GAPS THERE
CURRENTLY ARE THAT IS REALLY
USEFUL INFORMATION.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
INSPECTOR FORCE BECOME IT'S OWN
PROFESSIONAL GROUP.
AND BUILD ITS OWN.
ESPRIT AND BE A REALLY POSITIVE
FORCE FOR THE UPGRADING OF THAT
INSPECTION ROLE WITHIN THE
UTILITY.
MONITORING SAFETY DRAFT.
THE FACT IS SAFETY IS NOT A
BUILDING YOU BUILDING IT'S ONCE
AND FOR ALL IT'S A CONSTANT
PROCESS THAT DEGRADES AND HAS TO
BE RESTORED.
WHEN WE'VE LOOKED AT WHAT WE
CALL HIGH RELIABILITY
ORGANIZATIONS WHAT WE SEE IS NOT
VARIANCE?
WHAT WE SEE IS THE FLUCTUATION
IN REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE
ATTENTION THAT PEOPLE PAY
COMMUNICATION PROCESSES THAT
OCCUR AND DON'T OCCUR -- TRUST
BETWEEN THE UNITS.
THAT THE CASE AND THEY
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO MANAGE THESE
THEY LOOK FOR SIGNALS OF DECAY.
AND THEY BASICALLY DO WHAT THEY
CAN TO RENEW THE FERVOR AS ONE
PERSON PUT IT TO ME IN A NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT.
SO THEY MANAGED FLUCTUATIONS OF
THE AMPLITUDE IS NOT TOO GREAT.
THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE -- OF
THAT MONITORING OF SAFETY DRIFT
CAN ALSO BE DONE IN A UTILITY.
I MEAN IN A REGULATOR.
YOU SEE HAS SO MANY POLICIES
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE DEALING WITH
SIMULTANEOUSLY RENEWABLE FUELS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
OUR GLOBAL WARMING IS NOW A BIG
ISSUE APPARENTLY.
RATE AFFORDABILITY AS WELL AS
NOW WORRYING ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
COLLAPSE.
OF A MONOPOLY UTILITY AND THE
LOSS OF SERVICE THAT COULD COME
FROM THAT.
THAT'S A LOT TO PUT ON PEOPLE'S
PLATES AND SO IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT THE ATTENTION
FOCUSED ON SAFETY COULD DRAFT
[inaudible]
MAINTAINING.
READING WHAT WE CALL WEAK
SIGNALS OF THAT PROCESS
BEGINNING IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE SEE.
AS A REALLY CRITICAL ROLE FOR
THE OSL BUT THE I SAY IF IT
COULD BECOME INSTITUTIONALIZED.
SO THAT IT WOULD HAVE THE
SUPPORT.
UP THE COURAGE.
AND THE RESOURCES TO DO THAT.
ALSO THAT'S THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT WE THINK WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
YOU COULD IMAGINE EXTERNAL
ORGANIZATION REVIEWING THIS BUT
THEY HAVE TO INTERFERE ALL THE
TIME AND IT WOULD NOT BE AS
EFFECTIVE IT SEEMS TO US AS AN
IN HOUSE -- ONE BUT IT IS ALSO
AN AREA BY THE WAY WHERE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE COULD LOOK FOR
SIGNS AS WELL IN THEIR OVERSIGHT
ROLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FOCUS
ON SAFETY HAS NOT DEGRADED.
OVER TIME AND OVER ALL OF THE
STRESS AND THE OTHER FUNCTIONS
EXPERTS TO PERFORM [inaudible]
LASTLY.
CONTINUOUS PRESSURE FOR
IMPROVEMENT CHRIS TALKED ABOUT
THAT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT THING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE SAFETY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS THERE
EFFECTIVE ARE WORRIED THAT IF
THEY DON'T CONSTANTLY IMPROVE
THEY'RE GONNA GET WORSE.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A STEADY STATE.
COMPLACENCY WILL COME IN IF
YOU'RE NOT CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
GET BETTER.
AND THAT PRESSURE FOR GETTING
BETTER CAN BE DISTRIBUTED ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
IT CAN BE DISTRIBUTED DOWN AT
THE SHOP LEVEL IF PEOPLE SEE
BETTER PROCEDURES THAT COULD OR
PROCEDURES AND AREN'T WORKING
AND WAYS TO IMPROVE THEM.
AND USE THAT INFORMATION PUSH.
FOR IMPROVEMENT ONE OF THE BEST
NUCLEAR RUN NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS
WE SAW.
WAS REALLY INTERESTING THE SHOP
LEVEL PEOPLE OWN THE PROCEDURES
THEY WERE THE ONES WHO PROPOSED
NEW PROCEDURES REVISIONS AND
PROCEDURES AND CARRIED IT ALL
THE WAY THROUGH.
FORMAL PROCESS TO CHANGE THOSE
PROCEDURES THAT'S A KIND OF PUSH
AT THAT LEVEL BUT IT CAN OCCUR
EVERYWHERE THE OSA SHOULD BE
CONSTANTLY LOBBYING AND FEEL
POWERFUL ENOUGH TO DO IT. FOR
THE DEFECATION OF SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS NOT JUST WAITING
FOR UP [inaudible]
A PROCEED.
WHERE EVERYBODY'S IN A REACTIVE
MODE IN THEIR IN STATE
ADVERSARIAL RELATIONSHIP BUT
ACTUALLY PRO SUSPECTED PRO?
IDENTIFYING THINGS AND PUSHING
HARD I KNOW CHRIS WOULD LOVE TO
DO THAT IF YOU HAD MORE STAFF
AND IF THEY WERE.
IF HIS PROPOSALS WERE
INSTITUTIONALIZED WITH RESPECT
TO THE SUPPORT THE OSA HAS TO
MAKE THEM.
IN IN THE CPUC IN -- SO IN ANY
CASE THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
FUNCTIONS THAT WE THINK ARE
NECESSARY.
YOU'LL HAVE TO THINK THROUGH
CAREFULLY WHERE THEY SHOULD BE
PLACED OR HOW TO PROMOTE THEM --
BUT I THINK IT'S AT A CRITICAL
TIME FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE. FOR
ACTUALLY YOUR COMMITTEE TO
DECIDE OKAY WE'RE NOT I DON'T
THINK EITHER CARLINA RIGHTS ARE
CONFIDENT.
THAT THE TRAJECTORY AHEAD IS ON
SOME SORT OF AUTOMATIC PILOT TO
SAFETY WE DON'T SEE THAT AT ALL.
SO I THINK SOM MAJOR RETHINKING
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AT ALL
LEVELS AND IN ALL PLACES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
DOCTOR ROBERTS WOULD GIVE SOME.
CALLING.
AFTER FROM THE OF SIR THANK YOU.
I THINK DOCTOR ASSAULT SAID
ABOUT THE BEST IT COULD BE SAID
I MEAN WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THESE ISSUES. FOR QUITE AWHILE
NOW -- I HAVE WORKED OF WITH --
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO QUITE WELL
IN FACT IT WOULD LET ME UNLESS
THEY DID QUITE WELL BECAUSE I
TALK TOO MUCH -- AND SO THAT
THAT WERE DOING WELL I'D ALSO
SAY THAT BUT IN IN THAT IN THAT
INSTANCE YOU DO SEE -- HI TRUSTS
GOOD COMMUNICATION AND AND NOT
AN OVERLOAD IN FACT IF YOU HAVE
LOOKED AT THE NEWSPAPERS
RECENTLY ABOUT SEVERAL US NAVY
SHIPS THAT GOT INTO A LOT OF
TROUBLE.
IT WAS BECAUSE IT WAS SAID I I
DIDN'T LOOK AT SPECIFICALLY.
IT WAS SAID THAT PART OF WHAT
WAS LACK OF TRAINING.
AND PART OF WHAT WAS OVERLOAD
THEY HAD TAKEN PEOPLE CREW OFF
THOSE SHIPS.
AND SO THEY HAD TOO MANY PEOPLE
DOING -- DOING THE JOBS THAT
MORE PEOPLE SHOULD OF DONE ON ON
THOSE SHIPS AND SO I THINK THAT
THE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE SEEING
WITH -- CEBU SEE ARE ARE IN
GREAT PARK OVERLOAD.
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THAT
DISTRIBUTED BUT YOU CAN'T
DISTRIBUTED WITH ALSO JUST
WITHOUT ALSO DISTRIBUTING.
TRUST AND COMMUNICATION CAN'T BE
DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL WHAT I
WANTED IT'S IT'S THANKS FOR THAT
PRESENTATION IT'S KIND OF KIND
OF SET THE TONE I THINK IN AND
REYES A COUPLE OF OTHER ISSUES
AND AND ONE IN PARTICULAR THE
CAN I GUESS TO THE WHAT.
THE THREAT THRESHOLD QUESTION I
THINK THAT -- WE'RE INVOLVED
WITH INTER DURING THE JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE HEARING WE
HAD IN SANTA ROSA -- IT
PRESIDENT PICKER NOTED AND I'LL
QUOTE WE THIS IF YOU SEE WERE
NOT DESIGNED TO BE SPEEDY WE
WERE DESIGNED TO SLOW THINGS
DOWN.
AND WE LITIGATE EVERYTHING JUST
AS IF WE WERE A COURT OF LAW
WHICH CAUSE.
TO PROMOTION BECAUSE COMMENTS
ABOUT HOW THINGS JUST GONNA TAKE
TEN YEARS -- OR SOMETIMES THINGS
MOVE KIND OF SLOWLY BECAUSE THE
PROCESSES ARE SLOW PROCESS EASY
EQUALLY QUESTIONS SAFETY
REGULATION RATE MAKING
REGULATION OF THE UTILITIES.
BEING HOUSED IN THE SAME AGENCY
SO SELECT ASK USED ALL OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS -- DO YOU
BELIEVE ONE ORGANIZATION SHOULD
BE BOTH THE RATE REGULATOR AND A
SAFETY REGULATOR OR OR DO THESE.
KIND OF GOT A RESULT IN
UNTENABLE CONFLICTS BECAUSE OF
THEIR INHERENT NATURE AND IF
IT'S DONE IN ONE ORGANIZATION.
IT'S AN UPHILL CLIMB TO PROTECT
SAFETY.
IN RELATIONSHIP TO A HUGE
CONCENTRATION ON RATES.
BRINGING SAFETY INTO THE RATE
CASE.
IS INHERENTLY PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE SAFETY CAN'T BE MEASURED
IN THE SAME WAY THAT CAPACITY
AND COSTS ARE.
AND BECAUSE SAFETY.
IN A SENSE IF YOU HAVE SAFETY
THEN YOU.
IT'S HARD TO VALUE THINGS THAT
DON'T HAPPEN.
AND SO IT'S HARD TO BUILD UP A
HEAD OF STEAM TO RAISE RATES TO
IMPROVE SAFETY.
IF PEOPLE DON'T FEEL THAT IT'S A
CRISIS SITUATION AND THE OTHER
THING IS I'M AFRAID AND I HAVE
SEEN SOME EVIDENCE I WON'T SAY
WHERE.
OF UTILITY SIMPLY MANAGING THEIR
SAFETY TO THE RATE CASE.
IF THEY DON'T THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO GET.
A COMPENSATION IN RATES THAT IS
NOT A SAFE INVESTMENT THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE.
AND PART OF THE ISSUE IS TO FIND
A WAY TO STIMULATE.
THE UTILITIES THEMSELVES TO
UNDERTAKE SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS.
AND IF THE RATE CASE ISTHE WAY
THEY MANAGE SAFETY INVESTMENTS
THENSAFETY IT SEEMS TO ME IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE [inaudible]
A UNDER APPRECIATED AND UNDER
DEFENDED.
PROPERTY SO I THINK IT'S NOT
IMPOSSIBLE BUT IT'S A VERY
UPHILL BATTLE IN WE CERTAINLY
SAW THAT WITH P. JEANNIE AFTER
THE SAN BRUNO EXPLOSION I MEAN
THEY CERTAINLY DID MAKE MAJOR
IMPROVEMENTS IN THEIR GAS SYSTEM
I MEAN THEY WERE FORCED TO DO
THAT BY THE P. UC'S CERTAINLY.
AND BY THE LEGISLATURE. TO TO
IMPROVE THAT BUT THEY TOTALLY
NEGLECTED THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
HOUSE AND IN THAT'S WERE WERE
SHAPE YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THAT SAFETY IF THEY HAD THE
CULTURE AND IT HADN'T BEEN
INVOLVED IN RATE.
SINCE SOME FORM THEY WOULD HAVE
MADE THAT INVESTMENT OR FELT
THAT THEY COULD DO THAT AND
SHOULD HAVE DONE THAT SO.
I I THINK YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE
RIGHT IN THAT IT BUT I DON'T
KNOW BUT PRETTY MUCH AND WE HAVE
A WE HAVE IT AT TWO EXAMPLES OF
WHERE IT OF IF YOU REALLY WANT.
TO HAVE EXAMPLES OF WHERE THE
RATE SAFETY.
COMBINATION DOESN'T WORK AND ONE
IS IN THE MARITIME INDUSTRY
WHERE YOU HAD MINERAL MANAGEMENT
SERVICES.
DOING BOTH -- LOOKING AT SAFETY
AND RATES AND EVERYTHING ELSE
AND THEN WE HAD THE P..
AND THOUGH IT KILLED A LOT OF
FISH AND SOME PEOPLE AND DID A
LOT OF DAMAGE.
AND SO THE MIDDLE MANAGEMENT
SERVICE WAS CLOSED DOWN AND THAT
THE FUNCTIONS WERE DIVIDED INTO
TWO AGENCIES ONE OF WHOSE NAME
I'VE FORGOTTEN BUT THE OTHERS
BSE EATING.
THE OTHER EXAMPLES FUKUSHIMA.
WHERE YOU HAD -- OF INSTEAD OF
INCEST ESSENTIALLY BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THE PEOPLE WERE WHO HAD
WRITTEN CHARGE OF RATES AS
SAFETY ON THE REGULATORY SIDE
WE'RE CHANGING JOBS WITH PEOPLE
IN THE IN THE UTILITY.
AND THAT CAN GET TO BE A REALLY
DANGEROUS SORT OF THING WEEK
WE'VE.
HAD SOME EXAMPLES THAT HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT THAT
TURNED INTO A REALLY BIG AXIS SO
IF YOU NEED EXAMPLES OF WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE.
INDEPENDENT OF ONE OF THE THAT
THAT'S AT LEAST [inaudible]
TWO SOME.
ULTIMATELY THINK THE ODDS THEY
CAN BOOK WORK BOTH WAYS.
THERE ARE KNOWN.
IS.
A WOMAN'S.
OVER WHAT IT SEEKS TO HALL OF
THE ECHO.
OF FUNCTIONAL SAFETY PARADIGM
AND THAT THE CURRENT TO GAPS IN
THAT THAN THOSE GAPS NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED.
AND THEY NEED TO BE RESOLVED
WITHIN THEIR WITHIN THE P. YOU
SEE OR THAT THEIR EXTERNAL TO
THE PC AND THE SOME PROS AND
CONS TO DOING IT DIFFERENT WAYS
BUT ELEMENT EACH YEAR TO THIS
QUESTION ALL OF THE P. YOU SEE
HOW BEING THESE COMPETING
PRIORITIES IN THIS.
KIND OF INHERENT CONFLICT
BETWEEN RATE MAKING AND SAFETY
ELM YEAR THE UPSIDE OF HAVING A
SINGLE AGENCY TO DEAL WITH THIS
IS REFLECTS THE REALITIES OF
WHAT THE OPERATORS ARE DEALING
WITH.
BECAUSE SAFETY IS NOT THE ONLY
GOAL OF THE UTILITY THEIR YOUTH
THERE ARE YOU KNOW IT'S HERE TO
SERVE A PURPOSE.
AND WE PUT A LOT OF REQUIREMENTS
WE MEETING COLLECTIVELY RATES AS
AS A L. AS SOCIETY IT RATE OF
WHAT WE ONCE.
THE UTILITIES -- TOOL FOR FILL
RATES WE WE NEED THEM TO SERVE
AND PROVIDE POWER OF WILL
ELECTRIC WERE NATURAL GAS WE ARE
OR WARNING THEM TO MEET THE IN
HOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS AND
PROMOTES.
L. COULD CLAIM ITS IT CHANGE
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION ALL
GOALS AND RENEWABLES WE L. BUT
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
LECTURE FLYING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ALL OF
THESE GOALS ARE BEING SETS BY A
POLICY MAKERS.
HOME AND THE U. S. AND WE HOW
WILL BE ASLI THE COST ASPECTS OF
THE EARTH.
THAT'S IS A REALITY ALL OF THE
ENERGY SECTOR AND YOU CAN LAW IT
LOOK AT SEE.
IN ISOLATION FROM EVERYTHING
ELSE BECAUSE THE OPERATORS
HEALTH TO MAKE EL ECONOMIC HELP
TO MAKE THE ENTIRE THING WORK
AND WE NEED TO HEALTH POLICY --
THAT ALSO IS COHESIVE AND MAKES.
SENSE AS IN ITS TOTALITY FROM
CLOTH TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
ALL THE WAY THROUGH SAFETY AND
IF WE AS REGULATORS CAN LIGHT
RECONCILE OF THOSE PRIORITIES.
HELP HOW DO WE EXPECT THE
OPERATORS TO RECONCILE THEM.
ALL MAKE IT THE YIELD AND THE
WAY YOU THINK THAT.
ELEMENT THIS WHOLE NOTION THAT
WE CAN JUST MOVE SAFETY OVER
INTO SOMEWHERE ELSE AND THUS.
GET RID OF THOSE PROBLEM THAT
EXIST IN THE INDUSTRY IS A YOU
KNOW LOOKING FOR A SUITABLE
SHORT CUT UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T
BELIEVE EXISTS WE HOW OLD THE
YOU KNOW A BIG CHALLENGE.
L. IN IN THE IN THE IN THIS
INDUSTRY ELM.
AND WHERE THE HELL ALL YOU
ACTUALLY YOU WILL MAKE ALL OF
THE WORK SO I THINK IN THAT
SENSE ACTUALLY THERE IS A
BENEFIT TO HAVING. TO CONTINUING
HELPING THIS FUNCTION WITHIN THE
WITHIN THE COMMISSION THE SECOND
POINT THAT I WOULD ADD IS THAT
YOU DO THIS VERY THIS DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS. TO SAFETY FUNCTIONS
FROM E. L. FROM THE STATE'S AND
REGULATORY POINTS OF VIEW SO
THERE IS THE OUT THE POLICY
MAKING FUNCTION.
RATE WHEN YOU SET REGULATIONS
AND TELL THE UTILITIES WHAT TO
DEAL -- THERE IS THE THE SAFETY
ASSURANCE.
FUNCTION THERE'S DIDN'T FORCE
ONE FUNCTION THERE'S THE SAFETY
PROMOTION FUNCTION AND THEY'RE
NOT ALL NECESSARILY THE SAME SO --
HOME [inaudible]
EITHER.
IT -- WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE PC AND
WHAT SHOULD BE DOING?
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE ARE
YOU'LL SOME SO YOU KNOW WE GET
WE CAN BREAK THAT THAT QUESTION
UP A LITTLE BIT.
OHM'S SO SO.
FOUR YEAR WIN IT SO DOES ONE
ASPECT TO DO WITH POLICY.
L. UNIT ONE OF THE OTHER GAPS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT USES AN
EXAMPLE IS IN THE HOME IS IT IN
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND KIND OF
INSPECTION THAT WAS NEVER THE
FUNCTION OF THE PC IN THE
ELECTRIC SPACE WERE NEVER STAFF
DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY BE GOING.
OUT THERE AND INSPECTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AT SCALE.
HOME ALL WERE FIFTY FUNCTION AT
THE COMMISSION IS BASED ON THE
INVESTIGATION OF INCIDENTS AND
OUGHT IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
FUNCTION FOR BOOTS ON THE GROUND
KIND OF INSPECTION.
THE RIGHT NOW IT'S A GAP WE
PERFORM THIS SO.
THE BOOK MORE OF THAT ACTUAL
PHYSICAL INSPECTION.
ELEMENT THE WORK ON THE REAL
SIDE WHERE WE HOME INSPECTOR
SEXUALLY WALK TRACK.
ULTIMATE I DID SOME CALCULATIONS
SORT OF BACK OF THE ENVELOPE OF
WHAT KIND OF STAFFING WE WOULD
NEED ON THE ELECTRIC SIDE TO DO.
THE SAME KIND OF HAVE THE SAME
RATIO OF INSPECTORS.
ELEMENTS WHO INFRASTRUCTURE IS
WE DO ON RAIL SO.
WHAT WE DO ON RAILS ABOUT FORTY
PEOPLE JUST YOU KNOW JUST
THINKING MILES IT WOULD SEEK
WERE ABOUT?
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OF PEOPLE. TO DO
THE SAME LEVEL OF INSPECTIONS ON
THE ELECTRIC SIDE RATE SO WE'RE
ABOUT A THOUSAND PEOPLE AGENCY
THAT IS SET UP TO DO POLICY.
IF WE WERE TO INTRODUCE ANOTHER
THOUSAND THEN THE HEALTH PEOPLE
TO DO -- FIELD INSPECTION THAT
CHANGES FUNDAMENTALLY THE TYPE
OF AN AGENCY THAT WE ARE SO I
THINK WHEN WE'RE LOOKING IF THE
STATE WANTS.
TO CLOSE THIS GAP DOESN'T
DIFFERENT OPTIONS RATE WE CAN
HIRE YOU KNOW IN ADDITIONAL
THOUSAND OR SO PEOPLE OF THE P.
YOU SEE AND TRAIN THEM ON HOW
THAT AND HOUSE INSPECTION SOUTH
WE COULD.
DO THIS WITH THIRD PARTIES AND
CONTRACT.
RATE THAN INDEPENDENT EVALUATORS
OR WEAKENED HOUSE OF ONE ANOTHER
AGENCY LIKE HELL FIRE RATE THAT --
YOU KNOW MAYBE IS BETTER AND UP-TO HAVING A LARGE WORK FORCE.
WELL YOU KNOW THE OTHER THING
THAT ALL -- AND LEAVE IT YOU
KNOW OPEN FOR QUESTIONS BUT I
JUST WANT TO SAY ONE MORE THING
ABOUT YOU KNOW THIS WHOLE
QUESTION OF CREATING
[inaudible]
ANOTHER AGENCY [inaudible]
HOME. EIGHT A SINGLE TIMIDLY CAN
WORK BOTH WAYS LIKE I SAID LIKE
IF YOU WANTED TO PULL THE SAFETY
FUNCTION YOU EITHER IN THIS
ENTIRE DAY OR A PIECE OF IT OUT
OF THE P. YOU SEE AND CREATE
ANOTHER AGENCY I THINK IT CAN
WORK.
BUT IT IS YOU KNOW IT'S SIX TIME
IT'S SIX RESOURCES AND YOU KNOW
TO DO IT PROPERLY YOU KNOW WE
WOULD REALLY NEED TO BE FUNDED
THAT SCALE AND WHAT I'VE SORT OF
SEEING THE DRAFT ON THESE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN AS YOU
START OFF WITH TALKING WITH
CREATING ANOTHER AGENCY.
AND THEN YOU END UP JUST SAYING
WELL WE'LL JUST STICK IT WITHIN
LIKE OFFICE OF FIRE MARSHALL FOR
YOU KNOW ALL OR SOMEWHERE ELSE
YOU THE WITHIN THE STATE
STRUCTURE BECAUSE ONCE YOU START
DOING THE CALCULATIONS WITH AT
ACTUALLY IT SEEKS. TO SET UP AN
ENTIRELY INDEPENDENT AGENCY AND
THE NUMBER OF YEARS THAT WOULD
SEEK TO ESTABLISH IT IS IT'S
IT'S A MASSIVE LEFT RIGHT AND I
THINK IT'S HARD YOU KNOW FOR ME
RIGHT NOW LIKE.
YOU KNOW MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
IS ADDRESSING THE WHILE FOR A
CHALLENGE TO HELP IN THE STATE
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO CAN
WORK ON THESE KIND OF CHALLENGES
TO WORK CIVIL TEDIOUSLY ON EXCEL
RATING.
OUR RESPONSE TO WILD FIRES WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME TRAINS THE
ABOLITION MASSIVE NEW AGENCY
WE'RE JUST GONNA NOT HOW ENOUGH
PEOPLE.
IN THE STATES WHO ARE WELL
VERSED ENOUGH IN THESE ISSUES
WHO CAN DO BOTH SO I THINK THAT
SORT OF THE STRUGGLE THAT HALL
WAS IN THE HALL DO YOU ACTUALLY
DO IT AND IS IT SOMETHING THAT
WE REALLY WANT TO PRIORITIZE
RATHER THAN.
ENHANCING YOU KNOW THE STRUCTURE
THAT WE ALREADY HEALTH SO ANYWAY
A LOW ENOUGH NO SHAKE YOU FOR
THAT I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
COMMENT ABOUT HAVING THE
INSPECTORS OR THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTORS NECESSARY TO DO A
THOROUGH -- RESPONSIBLE JOB OF
OF INSPECTING THE CITY
ELECTRICAL SIDE -- BUT OBVIOUSLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT AND USING P.
GENIE IS AN EXAMPLE OF FROM WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS [inaudible]
DAISY.
THE QUALITY OF THEIR SEE WHAT
WOULD EVERYONE LOOK AT THIS
THEIR SAFETY EVALUATIONS THAT
JUST THE QUALITY OF THEIR SYSTEM
COMPARED TO ASSESS THE GENIE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
THERE WAS A MAJOR MAJOR
DIFFERENCE THERE.
WOULD THAT BE UNKNOWN TO THE P.
UC WOULD THEY NOT HAVE HAD SOME.
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
IS A DISTINCTION HERE OR THERE
COULD BE A PROBLEM WITH THE
SYSTEM THAT OF COURSE GOING BACK
TO THE GAS SYSTEM WE YOU KNOW
THERE WERE NO.
WE'LL ALARM SET WITH P. JEANNIE
IN THAT SYSTEM EITHER SO I GUESS
HOW DO WE WE HAVE A REGULATOR
HOW DO THEY ENFORCE THE
REGULATIONS ITSELF ENFORCEMENT
SELF REGULATED THAN IN A WAY.
ITSELF MONITORED.
SO OF THE AUDITS OF THOSE THOUGH
IS THAT THE MANNER IN WHICH YOU
DETERMINE WHETHER THERE IS A
PROBLEM AND THEY'RE NOT DOING
THEIR JOB.
OR DO WE HAVE TO DO WE WAIT TILL
THAT.
DISASTER WELL AB THEY THINK THAT
THIS YOU KNOW MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS TO THIS AND THERE'S A
EITHER THERE IS THE THE WORK ALL
KNOWING THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
MORE PROBLEMATIC OPERATOR AND
THEN.
THERE ARE THE LOVERS YES TO THE
YOU KNOW OF WHAT YOU CAN DO IN
THE REGULATORY SPACE TO GET THEM
TO CHANGE THE BEHAVIOR RATE IN
THOSE IT YET YOU CAN BE AWARE
THAT YOU HAVE AN OPERATOR WITH
ME BECAUSE ON THE PERFORMING.
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY BE IN THAT.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE THE INTENTION
TO ANY USE YOUR TOOLS CORRECTLY
THAT THE OPERATOR ACTUALLY
RESPONDS IN THE WILL IT IN THE
WAY THAT PRODUCES THE RESULT
THAT YOU WANT I MEAN YOU.
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE ON ON
THE BUT SINCE [inaudible]
HOURS EITHER OVER THOSE
OPERATORS RATE THEY WERE OUR OWN
ECONOMIC AND OTHER INCIDENTS OF
MECHANISMS THAT YOU CAN USE BUT
SOMETIMES THE FAIL RATE.
AND SO YOU KNOW YOU HOW OF
CERTAIN OF THEM.
IT CAN OF ECONOMIC AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES THAT YOU CAN SEND
RATE SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT
ENOUGH RATE SO YOU KIND OF HAVE
TO KEEP DEVELOPING YOU TOOL BOX.
IT IS THE THE IT IS A REGULATOR
AS TOWARDS PRESSURES YOU CAN
PORTS WELL THE REGULATED AND
CITY.
IN ORDER TO GET IT TO PERFORM IN
SUCH A WAY THAT PRODUCES THE
SOCIETAL RESULTS THAT WE WANT
RATE SO I THINK THERE'S A TWO
ZERO PARTS.
OF THIS -- YOU KNOW TO THIS
QUESTION THERE IS THE KNOWLEDGE
RATE IN THE MONITORING TO KNOW
HOW IS THE OPERATOR PERFORMING
IN IDENTIFYING ISSUES BEFORE THE
RESULT IN INCIDENTS.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO WHAT YOU
CAN DO ALL AND AS YOU GET INTO
SITUATIONS WHERE.
YOU THIS SONG METHODS.
OF ARNOLD WORKING YOU NEED TO
KEEP INCREASING YOUR CAPABILITY
PROBABLY IN BOTH OF THOSE
DOMAINS.
WAY IN IN GRAVITY TO THE NUMBER
OF INSPECTORS THE THAT THE FAA
FOR EXAMPLE I MEAN I DON'T THINK.
THEY DON'T HAVE INSPECTORS.
INSPECTING EVERY AIRPLANE THEY
DON'T HAVE INSPECTORS THAT ARE
OUT THERE CONSTANTLY.
MONITORING WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
AIRLINES I MEAN THERE IS SELF
REGULATION AND THEY HAVE
INTERNAL INSPECTORS I BELIEVE
THAT OUR PEOPLE FROM THE COMPANY
THAT ACTUALLY TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND AND AND DO
THE JOB THAT EXPECTED OF THEM
AND REQUIRED OF THEM BY.
THE FAA OR THE REGULATOR NAM
MAYBE JUMPING OUT OF OUT OF MY
REALM HERE BUT I WOULD THINK
THAT'S HOW IT WOULD OPERATE.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE FAA THE NRC.
HAS ITS OWN PEOPLE BUT THAT THE
FAA DOES USE IN EXPECTS TO HAVE
SOME INSPECTION DONE BY THE
COMPANIES THEMSELVES. ONE FLIGHT
A CLARIFICATION MAYBE TO BE MADE
HERE IS THAT.
WHEN I WAS TALKING ABOUT A LOT
OF INSPECTIONS?
I WAS NOT NECESSARILY TALKING
ABOUT PHYSICAL INSPECTIONS WERE
SOMEBODY GOES OUT AND LOOKS SO
ALL THE MILES OF RAIL OR THE
LINE.
BUT SAFETY MANAGEMENT MAN
ORGANIZATIONAL MANAGEMENT
INSPECTIONS WERE PEOPLE LOOK AT
MAYBE THEY'LL GO IN AND SAMPLE
SOME WORK PLANNING SESSIONS FOR
EXAMPLE OR SIT IN ON A MEETING.
AND SEE WHAT'S BEING DONE AT THE
SUPERVISORY LEVEL OR SPEND THE
DAY IN A CONTROL ROOM AND SEE
WHAT PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY DOING
AND WHAT PRESSURES THERE UNDER.
AND I THINK.
THERE IS THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
IN SAFETY MANAGEMENT.
THAT IRRESPECTIVE OF THE ASSET
AND THE THE A TECHNOLOGY TYPE.
ARE IMPORTANT ACROSS THOSE
SYSTEMS AND PEOPLE THAT THEY
KNOW WHAT TO LOOK FOR IN A
SAFETY CULTURE IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATION PATTERNS.
ETCETERA AND SAFETY MANAGEMENT.
COULD.
COULD DO THAT WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO OUT AND LOOK ALL OVER THE
ENTIRE GEOGRAPHY FOR EXAMPLE OF
A UTILITY.
DIRECTOR YOU COMFORTABLE WITH --
ESSAYS. TWO YEAR TENURE THE WORK
THEY'VE DONE.
AND WHERE DO YOU THINK THEY
COULD EXPAND THAT OR DO A BETTER
JOB OF AND BEEN FORESEEN IN
BRINGING IN A SAFETY SYSTEM.
MANAGEMENT TO THE UTILITIES AND
WITHIN THE P. UC [inaudible]
OWN.
A SINGLE WAS THE HOUSE ADDED
VALUE HOME.
A THINK THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
THE DIALOGUE ABOUT THE SAFETY
FUNCTIONS THAT WE WANT THE PC TO
PLAY -- AND HOW TO STRUCTURE
LONG HOME AND THIS AGAIN THERE'S
DIFFERENCE WAYS THAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH IT YOU KNOW THEY
THINK THAT THERE ARE.
A COUPLE OF CHALLENGES WITH HOW --
THE CITY WAS DESIGNED THAT HAS
SO SORT OF PLEA DEALT THROUGH
THIS PILOT PHASE.
THAT ANYTHING COULD BE HOPEFUL
WHO -- RESOLVE OR OR CLARIFY.
HOME ONE OF THIS THOUGH IS THE
WHOLE QUESTION OF SAFETY
ADVOCACY WHAT THAT MEANS.
ELEMENT IN THE UC CONTEXT
ADVOCACY MEANS SOMETHING VERY
SPECIFIC.
ELEMENT.
AND THERE IS THE THE REAL GOOD
REASONS FOR FOR THAT OF RATE
THEY THERE IS THE HUGE.
ELM EVERYTHING THE YOU KNOW THE
ANY -- ORGANIZATION ANY ANY TYPE
ANYTIME YOU HALL THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK IT NEEDS TO HELP THE
PROCESS HOUSE WAYS TO COLLECT
INFORMATION THINK THROUGH ISSUES
AND RESOLVE THEM RIGHT THE P.
YOU SEE HIGHS CERTAIN PROCESS AS
ITS STRENGTH AND WEAKNESSES RATE.
BUT ADVOCACY MEANS A VERY
SPECIFIC THING AND IT HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE.
OF AND THEN EIGHT THINK WHAT
HAPPENING WITH GO WITH SAY IS
THAT THE SORT OF THE CAPITAL
LETTER FORMAL ADVOCACY GETS
COMPLETED WITH AN INFORMAL WAY
YOU USE ADVOCACY IN TERMS OF A
PROMOTER.
IT IS THE YOU KNOW WITH SOMEBODY
WHO'S A SAFETY EXPERT AND
PROMOTE SAFETY IS A MOTION.
AND IN THE P. YOU SEE CONTACTS
IN AND IT DOES TWO THINGS AREN'T
NECESSARILY THE SAME THING OR
SHOULD BE THE SAME THING AND
CONFLATING NUMBERS CREATING.
CERTAIN ISSUES SO THAT YEAR I
THINK IT KIND OF IF I CAN SEEK
ONCE THE BACK -- SOMETHING THAT
THE THE BACKGROUND PAPERS
TALKING ABOUT AND SENATE HELLO I
THINK YOU PHONE.
HOW ABOUT IN YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS IS THIS?
QUESTION ABOUT REAP MAKING AS
THE ELM IS A MECHANISM AND WHERE
IT HOUSE YOU KNOW THAT THAT SORT
OF THE PC FOR PRIMARY WAY OF
DEALING WITH THINGS AND
WAREHOUSE STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES IN THE MAY BE
COMPARING IT TO THE BECAUSE I
LEGISLATIVE.
WAY WELL EACH YEAR. TO ME EITHER
THE QC DOESN'T GENERALLY
FUNCTIONS THE COURTHOUSE -- YEAR
THAT IS HOW IT HAS DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PROCEEDINGS AND
DIFFERENT MECHANISMS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT RULES BUT ULTIMATELY
IT WAS SET UP TO ALLOW.
FOUR ELM.
CONSIDERATION BUT FOR ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT INVOLVED IN
THE ISSUES TO COME IN ARGUE
THEIR POINTS AND THEN FOR A FAIR
PROCESS TO EVALUATE FACTS AND
THEN COME TO BALANCE DECISION
THAT IS.
THE CORE OF HOPE YOU SEE
FUNCTIONS RATE.
AND IN CERTAIN AREAS IT DOES
WORK WE WILL WORK FAIRLY WELL UL
LI CREEK MAKING AS AN EXAMPLE
WHERE YOU HAVE A UTILITY ASKING
FOR MONEY AND THEN THE REPAIR
INTRAVENOUS COME AND THEN ARGUE
THEIR POINTS AND THEN YOU KIND
OF THAT LAND IN THE MDDLE
SOMEWHERE.
IT'S WORKED VERY WELL IN -- WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RENEWABLES?
BECAUSE YOU HOW OF ORGANIZED
LOBBIES L. FOR SOLAR DEVELOPERS
FOR EXAMPLE FOR VERY ELOQUENCE.
TO ARGUE THEIR POINTS AGAIN YOU
YOU HAVE A RECORD THAT'S
BALANCED OR BASED ON WHICH YOU
COMMISSION CAN WEIGH THE FACTS
AND AND COME UP WITH SOME.
DECISIONS IN THE CASE OF SAFETY
THAT NATURALLY DOESN'T ARISE SO
THAT IS THE NEW.
THE P. YOU SEE PROCESS IN THIS
IN THE CASE OF SAFETY WHETHER
IT'S READ SETTING BECAUSE THEY
LEGISLATOR OF WERE ANYTHING ELSE.
DOZENS.
IT BREAKS DOWN BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HEALTH PARTIES.
OUT THERE WHO ADVOCATES FOR
SAFETY AND WELL IN IT THERE IS
NO WAY FOR THEM TO ARISE.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ECONOMIC
CONSENSUS EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
SORT OF MAKE A LIVING RATE.
ELEMENTS SO [inaudible]
THE SAFETY ADVOCATES.
YOU KNOW FOR ME AGAIN THE FORMAL
POINTS OF VIEW THERE IS THIS GAP
WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE ANYBODY WHO
SERVE PROVIDES THIS INFORMATION
INTO THE RECORD.
RATE IN THE RISEN IMPORTANT
FUNCTION. TO HAVE SOMEBODY DO
THAT.
RATE SO THAT THE RATE IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A DIALOGUE
AND DEBATE AND THAT WAS FROM A
FORMAL POINT OF VIEW OF WHAT IS
A SAFETY.
OFFICE OF CT ADVOCATE CAN
PERFORM THIS FORMAL ADVOCACY AND
I DON'T WANT TO DISCOUNT THAT
AND I DO THINK THAT THAT IS A
FUNCTION.
THAT SQUARE -- SAY HAS DONE WELL
IN AND GIVEN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES CAN DO AN EVEN BETTER
JOB AT BUT IT DOESN'T SOLVE.
ALL OF THESE FOR ALL OF PROBLEMS
WELL WILL SHORTCOMINGS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THEIR SAFETY
PARADIGM YOU KNOW IT JUST THE
YOU KNOW SEE IF THE ADVOCACY ON
THE RECORD IT IS A GAP.
IT NEEDS TO GET FILLED IN THE
WITH SAY CAN FILL IT AND IF WE
CAN GIVE IT GET MORE RESOURCES I
THINKING CAN DO IN A REALLY GOOD
JOB.
BUT THERE ARE MANY OTHER AREAS
WHERE WE CURRENTLY.
EL HALL OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
CASE THAT WE NEED TO LUMP
EVERYTHING ON TO ALWAYS SAY TO
TO SORT OF FULL BLOWN RATE.
SO ELM SOME OF THE EXAMPLES.
FOR THE RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH DOCTOR
SHULMAN ON THE US YOU KNOW AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED ONE OF THE
BIGGEST GAPS THAT WE HAVE IN
SAFETY.
IS ACTUALLY IN THE IN.
THE IN THE FACT THAT WE DON'T.
HOW OF ANYBODY WHO IS DEDICATED
TO SAFETY POLICY?
ARM AND THEY KIND OF LINE THAT
UP WITH RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS
THAT YOU WE DON'T HAVE.
STAFF OR RESOURCES OR ANYONE WHO
ACTUALLY STUDIES SAFETY AND
COMES UP WITH PROPOSALS AND SO
AND AGAIN IT'S A DIFFERENT
FUNCTION FROM ADVOCACY.
RATE IT YOU KNOW WEEK IT IS AND
THE YEAR WE NEED IT AND I'M
TRYING TO DO THIS RIGHT NOW IN
THE WILD FIRE SPACE.
WHERE WE HAVE THIS IS SORT OF SB
NINE A ONE RATE THAT SETS UP THE
WELFARE MITIGATION PLAN THIS IS
A FANTASTIC EXAMPLE OF WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT? TO THE ITEM
TO GET SET UP AS UTILITIES FILES
THE PLAN IN THE AND THEN THE PC
NEEDS TO EVALUATE THEM MAKE A
DECISION SO UTILITY FILE THEIR
PLAN.
RIGHT WE'LL STOP THE WEEK
COMMISSION IS DESIGNED AREN'T
SET UP TO COME UP WITH A COUNTER
PROPOSAL TO THIS RIGHT YOU
RESPONDING TO WOULD BE UTILITIES
FILED.
AND THEN WAS SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT
THE RECORD THAT THAT GETS THE
BALL GOOD OVER THIRTY PARTIES
THE JOIN THOSE PROCEEDINGS.
WHEN WE WERE PLANNING FOR
WORKSHOPS I SEND OUT?
A REQUEST TO THE PARTIES TO SAY
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HOP SOME SOME
WORKSHOPS AND WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE DECISION MANAGEMENT.
AND ALL WHO WHO AND CODED
CONDUCTORS.
AND I WANNA HALL OF EXPERTS.
THE OWNER IN THE WORKSHOP WERE
ACTUALLY HAVE EXPERTISE IN THESE
TOPICS.
ALL MY WHO.
WE YOU KNOW WE DO SOME
QUESTIONING IN DISCUSSION WITH
UTILITIES DO ANY OF THE PARTIES
HAVE EXPERTS.
THEY DIDN'T RATE BECAUSE DORAL
SPECIAL INTERESTS GROUPS LIKE
FULLER OR MICHAEL GOOD
DEVELOPERS OR WHATEVER WHO DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE IN THE US.
AND THE STAFF AGAIN WE WERE
NEVER SET UP. TO HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE EITHER THE ROLE OF
ADVISORY STAFF OF THE COMMISSION
IS TO LOOK AT THE RECORD AND ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT INFORMATION THE
PARTIES A SUBMITTED AND HOPE THE
JUDGE MAKES SENSE OF THE RECORD.
IT'S NOT TO DEVELOP OUR OWN
RECORD THE RIGHT NOW IT'S A
COMPLETE GAP BREAK SO I MEAN WE
KIND OF DID THE THE BEST WE
COULD WITH THIS FIRST ROUND BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IT
JUST CAME OUT OF ANOTHER HEARING
FOR BUDGET FOR ME REALIZE IS.
FOR CONSULTING MONEY SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY P. SOMEONE'S WHO'LL
COME IN AND BRING THIS EXPERTISE.
TO DEVELOP SOME OF THE CRITERIA
FOR WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
AT THE WE CAN USE KIND OF AS A
STAFF PROPOSAL.
THAT IS SOMETHING OTHER THAN THE
JUST THE UTILITY POINTS OF VIEW
THEN THEN YOU CAN SORT OF USE AS
A BASIS.
FOR EACH YEAR OLD FROM.
FOR FOR HELPING THE EAGLE.
THE DIRECTION IN WHICH WE WANT
THE UTILITIES TO GO IN IN THE
VALUATION CRITERIA BUT THIS
EXAMPLE THAT WAS STRUGGLING WITH
THEM WILD FIRES AT THE PLACE
ACROSS THE BOARD RATE.
SO IT UNLESS YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
IN ORDER FOR US TO MAKE --
IMPROVEMENTS IN SAFETY OVER LONG
TERM WE HAVE TO START ADDRESSING
THIS MUCH EARLIER THAN WHERE WE
ARE RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW GO ON THE
AS YOU KNOW THE QUITE A FEW
THESE INCIDENTS AND EVERY SINGLE
TIME THAT SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS
I DON'T KNOW IT'S LIKE.
IN SAFETY EVERYBODY ALWAYS GOES
TO ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE AS
THE SOLUTION RATE.
AND THAT HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE
DON'T GET ME WRONG BUT WE DON'T
DO THAT IN OTHER AREAS YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO PROMOTE YOU
KNOW RENEWABLES OR SOMETHING
ELSE SOMEBODY JUMPS TO
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE IS
THE SOLUTION YOU START POLICY
RATE.
AND HOW BEING YOU KNOW AN
ARTICULATION OF WHAT YOU
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND
THEN SAFETY WERE ALWAYS STARTING
AT THE BACK THE FILMING.
THE DOES REGULATIONS ALREADY
TAKE YOU KNOW EXIST AND SO AGAIN
I THINK TO JUST TROOPS ARE AT NO
AT THEY WON THE LONG.
ANSWER HERE BUT I DON'T KNOW FOR
WITH STATE NEEDS TO KIND OF SOLD
ALL OF THOSE PROBLEMS I THINK
THEY'VE DONE WELL ON THE FORMAL
ADVOCACY PIECE IN THE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND WE
SHOULD EVALUATE HOW TO CLOSE.
SOME OF THOSE OTHER GAPS AROUND
RESEARCH ANALYSIS AND JUST
POLICY DEVELOPMENTS AND ALWAYS
SEE MAY OR MAY NOT BE LIKE THE
THE PRIMARY WAY OF ACHIEVING NOT.
DO THAT BUT HOW DO YOU SEE THEM
IT IN ANOTHER ROLE I MEAN.
TAKING MORE.
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN LOOKING AT
THE UTILITIES AND LOOKING AT IN
NOT JUST DURING RATE CASES BUT
IN [inaudible]
NO.
LOOKING IT'S BEING THAT SAFETY
ADVOCATE IN ADVOCATE IN WHATEVER
HOWEVER WE WANTED TO FIND IT BUT
NOT JUST AS AN ADVOCATE IN A
RAPE CASE BUT AN ADVOCATE IN
TRYING TRYING TO PROMOTE THAT.
AND ALSO SAFETY WITHIN THE CPUC
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT CULTURE
IS IS THERE AND AS WE KNOW THAT.
THAT HASN'T BEEN THE CASE IN THE
PAST.
YEAR I THINK THAT ELEMENT THERE
IS CONFLICT OVER HAVING THE
FORMAL SAFETY ADVOCATES WHO ALSO
HAS A FUNCTION WITHIN THE
COMMISSION.
OF ME.
BECAUSE WHEN.
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY ARE IN THEIR
FORMAL ADVOCACY ROLE
[inaudible]
OF THE ORG ALMOST LIKE AN
EXTERNAL PARTY AND HARMING THE
SAME PEOPLE SORT OF TELL THE
COMMISSION WHAT TO DO AND HOW TO
DO ITS ROLE AND THEN BE A PARTY
TO THE CASE THAT THE COMMISSION
DECIDES IT'S AN IT'S AN INHERENT
CONFLICT.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T DO THAT THEN
RATE LIKE WHAT RATE OR IT
DOESN'T TELL ENERGY DIVISION
HALL TO DO ALL YOUR BILL RATE
MAKING ON ONE HAND WHAT'S ALL
THE COMMISSIONERS OF HALL TOOL
YOU KNOW.
SORT OF THE VALUE IT RATES AND
THEN ALSO ACT AS A PARTY IN
COMMISSIONS PROCEEDING SO A
THINK I DON'T SEE A CONFLICT IN.
A WITH SAY.
BEING A LARGER ADVOCATES IN THE
UTILITIES SPACE AND ENGAGING
WITH UTILITIES BOTH YOU KNOW IN
THE CONTEXT ALL OF YOU THE
LITIGATION WITHIN.
L. EITHER AS AN ADVOCATE AND
THEN ALSO CAN OF GENERALLY
PROMOTING ELM YOU'LL SAFETY YOU
THOUGH CULTURE AND AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
A BOY A DO YOU THINK THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT SAFETY ADVOCATES
WERE YOUR ROLE IS TO BE THE
LEADING GAUGE BY JUST.
BY THE THE NATIONAL FORMAL
ADVOCACY.
WITHIN THE COMMISSION PROCEEDING
AND ALSO HOW OF THIS KIND OLD.
TELLING THE COMMISSION HELL TO
DO ITS JOB FUNCTION EIGHT THING
THAT SHOULD GET DE CONFLICTED IN
MY OPINION PUT IT INTO THE THIS
USUALLY HAVE THE SAFETY ACTION
PLAN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO THAT
IS THAT.
ELEMENT GOT REPLACED BY THE
SAFETY STRATEGIC DIRECTIVES --
THE EITHER YOU JUST DO THIS TOO
MANY COMPETING KIND OF WELL L.
PARADIGM SO WE HAVE THE SAFETY
ACTION PLANS BEFORE THE
COMMISSION ONCE WITH THE
STRATEGIC DIRECT OF EXERCISE.
AND NOW HOW OLD.
WE HOW ALL OF THIS THIS
STRATEGIC DIRECTORS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED BY THE QUé WE HAVE
THE SAFETY VISION THE SAFETY OF
THE STRATEGIC DIRECTOR OF AND
THEN THE MECHANISM THROUGH WHICH
THE COMMISSION EVALUATES.
THE PERFORMANCE OF PC STAFF IN
FULFILLING THAT STRATEGIC
DIRECTIVES THERE ISN'T A
SEPARATE SAFETY ACTION PLAN. TO
WHOSE ACTUALLY WORKING ON
DEVELOPING SOME LONG TERM.
YOU KNOW SAFETY VISION WITHIN
THE P. UC IS THAT IN THAT
DIRECTIVE.
FOR IS ANYONE DOING THAT TODAY.
YES A A THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
IT HAPPENS A DIFFERENT LEVELS
FLOW THERE ARE.
THIS LEAF TEA THE STRATEGIC
DIRECTIVE PROCESS IS REALLY.
WHERE THE COMMISSIONERS GET TO
COMMUNICATE WITH STUFF
RATE BECAUSE THE GOOD THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SET BY THE
COMMISSIONERS AS THE BODY AND
THE SAFETY DIRECTIVES PROCESS IS
THE THE THE FEEDBACK MECHANISM
ELSE TO HOW THE THOUGHT OFFICE
FULL.
OUT THOSE OBLIGATIONS AND WHERE
THE COMMISSIONER C. L.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENTS
AND AND SO ON YOU KNOW AND THEN
THAT HAPPENS AT DIFFERENT LEVELS.
SO L. -- IT OPENS FIRMS ALL OF
IT HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED BY STAFF
IN WHAT THE SAFETY VISION IS FOR
THE AGENCY -- IN MY VIEW THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ALSO MONTHLY
OWNS THAT'S AS THE HAD ALL OF
THE OF THE COMMISSION.
ELEMENT AND THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR FOR SAFETY IN THE
FORCE ONE POLICY IS.
THE PERSON WHO IS SORT OF THE
PRIMARY.
ADVISER TO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR ON MATHS AND IS THE
PERSON WHO WAS SORT OF
RESPONSIBLE FOR FOR DEVELOPING
THAT UNIFIED ELM.
VISION AND THEN THE INSURING
THAT OLD EIGHT DIFFERENT GROUPS
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN CARRYING IT
OUT THERE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
PERFORMING THAT FUNCTION.
THERE BEEN SOME CHANGES IN YOU
JUST GET OF REFERRING TO THE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE P. UC AND HOW
THINGS FIT IN THERE BEEN SOME
RECENT CHANGES -- AND IS A IS
NOW UNDER.
VIA A CD IS THAT CORRECT NO NO
THERE'S STILL SEPARATES.
DIVISION ELEMENTS SO THE END WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH THE DETAILS
OF HOW.
CAN OF TO FUNCTIONALLY SPLIT ITS
BUT THE ELM.
THE VISION IS FOR THE FOR THE L..
FIFTY ANON FORSMAN FUNCTIONS THE
FULL ON THE ONE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THEN YOU HOLDEN
DEPENDING TO UNITS UNDERNEATH
THAT SO SAFETY LOW FORSMAN
DIVISION.
WITH DIESEL DIVISION WITH THE
DIRECTOR OFFICE OF SAFETY
ADVOCATES IS A SEPARATE DIVISION
WITH THE WRONG DIRECTOR.
AND THE THE ROLE OF THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SAFETY IN
THE FIRST MONTH IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT ACROSS ALL THE FUNCTIONS
FROM POLICY MAKING.
YOU KNOW THE ADVOCACY ADVISORY
ENFORCEMENTS THAT EACH OF THOSE
ELEMENTS FUNCTIONS ULTIMATELY IN
THE EVERYTHING MAKE SCHOOL HE SO --
COHESIVE SENSE BUT IS THE IDEAS
THAT THE EACH UNIT WOULD STILL
HAVE COMPLETED THE PENDANT SO
THERE IS NO YES ALWAYS SAY WOULD
NOT BE ABSORBED BY SIXTEEN THE
HORSEMEN DIVISION BECAUSE OF THE
FROM FUNCTIONS AND ROLES FOR
FALL.
HE AND HE IS.
HOW IS -- IS A DIFFERENT FROM --
THE RISK ASSESSMENTS SAFETY
ADVISER.
WELL AGAIN THE MAIN THE MAIN
THEIR FRIENDS IS IN.
THE FUNCTIONAL ROLE WITHOUT THE
CASEY -- IS THE I THINK THE CORE
ALL OF THE OF WHAT THE ALWAYS
SAY WILL SET UP TO ADDRESS WAS
THE GAP THAT THERE WAS NO FORMAL
INTERVENOR.
IN BRIEFCASES SPECIFICALLY BUT
THEN OTHER PROCEEDINGS WALL THE
ADVOCATE.
FOR SIXTY RISK ASSESSMENTS WAS
NEVER YOU THAT WAS ALWAYS
WORKING IN THE ADVISORY FUNCTION
AND BOTH.
ARE NECESSARY BECAUSE YOU NEED
STAFF TO SUPPORT COMMISSIONERS
AND THE L. O. IN ADMINS SHOULD
LAW JUDGE.
IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE
RECORD DRAFTING OF DECISIONS
CREATING STUFF PROPOSALS THINGS
LIKE THAT AND YOU NEED SOMEBODY
ON THE RECORD WHO ACTUALLY.
HAS A POSITION AND DOES A TO TWO
DIFFERENT NEEDS AND BOTH OF THEM
HAVE TO BE -- NO MATTER
[inaudible]
PACEY THE THE END OF IT THE
COUPLE MORE THINGS HERE IN IN --
WE CAN WRAP UP BUT WANTED TO
CONTINUE KIND OF A DISCUSSION ON
ON THE CULTURE -- NOT WITHIN AN
ORGANIZATION AS IMPORTANT AS
THAT IS BUT THE CULTURE BETWEEN
THE REGULATED UTILITIES AS WE
SEE IT AND THEIR REGULATOR -- IN
WHAT WHAT CULTURE KINDA DRIVES
SAFETY WHAT WHAT.
HOW CAN WE? TO THAT POINT TO
WHERE THERE IS A A SAFETY.
CULTURE OF THAT IN SAFETY IS
PART OF THAT CULTURE HOW HOW
DOES THAT -- HOWEVER THAT THAT
WORK.
YEAH.
AS USUAL -- SO THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION.
AND LIKE MANY QUESTIONS THAT SO
EASY ANSWER BUT I THINK THE THE
ISSUE IS THAT.
SAFETY IS A ONGOING PROCESS THAT
IS -- PENETRATES THROUGH MANY
LAYERS.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK -- LIZA
BETTER REYES REALLY INTERESTING
POINT WHEN SHE TALKED ABOUT WELL
THE SAFETY THROUGH MANY
DIFFERENT FUNCTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH SAFETY THAT'S CERTAINLY
TRUE -- BUT I THINK THAT --
SAFETY IS SPECIAL I MEAN SHE'S
RIGHT THERE YOU DON'T HAVE A
SEPARATE.
ADVOCATE FOR SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONALLY AND THERE'S A
REASON FOR THAT AND PART OF IT
IS BECAUSE A LOT OF THE SAFETY
CULTURE IS INTERNALIZED IN
INDIVIDUALS IT'S NOT A FORMAL
STRUCTURE.
IT PEOPLE INTERNALIZE IT AND IT
BECOMES SORT OF A COLLECTIVE
GOOD.
AND RARELY DO YOU FIND
INDIVIDUAL GROUPS ARGUING FOR A
COLLECTIVE GOOD IT'S MOST OFTEN
A SPECIALIZED.
I I THINK YOU HAVE TO TREAT
SAFETY IS SPECIAL AND I THINK
YOU WOULD ASO HAVE TO SAY.
SAFETY ADVOCACY CAN'T BE JUST
LIKE [inaudible]
RATE ADVOCACY.
RENEWABLE ADVOCACY IT'S A
SPECIAL PROPERTY.
AND SO -- WHEN WE'VE SEEN IT IN
OPERATION?
IT GOES ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE
INDIVIDUAL IDENTITY OF PEOPLE
WORKING IN SPECIFIC TASKS.
WHO BASICALLY THINK ABOUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING FOR OTHERS SYSTEM RISKS IN
AN ORGANIZATION?
WHO AYE I WOULD USE THE USE THIS
EXAMPLE I WAS INTERVIEWING
SOMEBODY A CHEMIST IN -- POWER
PLANT NUCLEAR POWER PLANT.
AND HE'S SITTING IN HIS OFFICE
IN IS A NOISE IS WHAT IS THAT
NOISE I NEVER HEARD THAT BEFORE
HE RUSHES OUT OF THE ROOM AND
LEAVES ME.
I'M JUST SITTING THERE ANY COMES
I HAD TO KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
HE COULD NOT BE THE PERSON HE
WAS WITHOUT RUNNING OUT TO FIND
OUT WHAT THAT WHAT THAT WAS.
AND SO THE IT'S IT'S A STATE OF
MIND THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE FOR
THAT THAT'S THE CULTURE THE
DRIVE SAFETY EYES AND I BELIEVE
IT GOES THROUGH ALL OF THE LIGHT
LAYERS WE CALL PEOPLE.
RELIABILITY PROFESSIONS WE SAW
THEM IN A LITTLE HUGE NUMBER OF
INFRASTRUCTURES THAT WE LOOKED
AT WHO SAW.
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY AS BIGGER
THAN THEIR JOB.
THEY WOULD GO BEYOND THEIR JOB.
THEY WOULD SEE A SYSTEM LEVEL
RISK WHERE THEIR JOB DIDN'T CALL
FOR THEM TO EVEN.
WORRY ABOUT THOSE KINDS OF RISKS
SO IT'S IT'S A PROCESS OF PEOPLE --
HAVING THIS IDENTIFICATION --
HAVING A RESTLESS.
DRIVE TO MAKE THINGS BETTER FROM
A SAFETY.
THAT THEY HAVEN'T THOUGHT OF
EVERYTHING NEVER ALWAYS WORRIED
ABOUT BEING COMPLACENT.
AND THAT THAT KIND OF UP PROCESS.
IS A CRITICAL ELEMENT IN THE
SAFETY CULTURE AND IT'S NOT EASY
TO JUST CREATE THAT -- BUT
THAT'S WHAT WHAT WE SEE IT
SAFETY ISN'T JUST NEW TECHNOLOGY
AND NEW SYSTEMS IT'S THAT THAT
PROCESS AND THAT'S BEEN SO
DISTINCTIVE.
IN THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT THAT
WE'VE LOOKED AT SO.
AND THAT THAT THESE RELIABILITY
PROFESSIONALS AS WE'D TURN COPS
SAW BEYOND THEIR OWN
ORGANIZATIONS WE WENT TO THE
CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT
WHICH WAS FROM OUR STANDPOINT A
REALLY WELL MANAGED HIGH
RELIABILITY UNIT.
AND WHEN THEY STARTED TO TALK
ABOUT THEIR WATER PROCESSING
THEY SAW THROUGH THE LENS OF
THEIR CLIENTS.
IT WASN'T JUST WE GOT TO GET THE
STUFF OUT THERE THEY THOUGHT
THIS IF WE SCREW UP HERE I KNOW
WHAT IT'S GOING TO DO WITH THE
CITY OF X..
AND SO THE I DON'T KNOW QUITE.
HOW YOU CREATE THAT BUT I JUST
THINK IT'S DIFFERENT THAT'S WHY
WHEN I THINK OF SAFETY ADVOCACY
I DON'T THINK OF IT IN THOSE
FORMAL TERMS I DON'T THINK IT'S
PRODUCTIVE? TO ASSUME THAT THE
OS A WILL SIMPLY COUNTER.
OTHER OTHER ADVOCATES FOR OTHER
THINGS IN PROCEEDINGS IF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
UNDERSTOOD TO BE SPECIAL.
AND IN THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE REALLY GOOD IT IS SPECIAL
PARTLY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SO
WORRIED ABOUT.
THE HAZARDS THERE'S A PUBLIC
DREAD THAT THE MAKES THEM.
YOU KNOW TAKE THIS ON BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT KIND OF DREAD BUT UP
IN THE HOW DO YOU BALANCE THE
FACT THAT IF YOU HAVE A UTILITY
AND AND IF FOR UTILITIES
NEGLIGENT AND AND THE REGULATOR
FINDS OUT FINDS THEM PUNISHES
THEM IN SOME WAY. FOR THE REST
OF YOUR AND AND AND CORRECTS
THAT -- HE DID.
WOULD THAT IT HAS THAT LED TO A
CAñADA LEAD.
TO KNOW KIND OF A DISTRUST IN
AND A COMMUNICATION AND AND
TRUST ISSUE WILL THE THE
REGULATOR ON NEVER FIND OUT IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
NEVER GONNA TELL THEM WITH THE
SAFETY IT FIND AND HOW I THINK I
KNOW THAT IN THEIR EYES ARE OVAL
THING OF THE FUTURE.
HE WAS.
WAS CRITICIZED FOR THE FACT THAT
THEY DID NOT FIND AND DID NOT
TAKE IT SERIUSLYA NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO WITH THAT THAN THEY
WERE TRUST IN THE UTILITIES. TO
TO DO THE JOB FIND THE PROBLEM
AND FIX THE PROBLEM REPORT THE
PROBLEM AND THEN YOU'RE OKAY AND
THE FINE DIDN'T SEEM TO WORK THE
FINE IS A PROCESS OF RETRIBUTIVE.
JUSTICE.
IT IS NOT A PROCESS OF RESTORED
INITIAL SOLVE THE PROBLEM
TOGETHER.
AND MOST -- THE REGULATORS WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
DON'T SEEM TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
WITH THEIR REGULATE PEOPLE I
WANT TO GO BACK IF YOU.
DON'T MIND THE SOMETHING YOU
SAID ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES AGO
WHERE I THINK YOU SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WORK WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
AND LET'S SEE IF I CAN GET A
RIDE IF I DON'T GET A RIGHT TO
YOU CORRECT ME BACK HE SAID.
YEAH YOU NEED MORE RESOURCES
THAT'S ONE THING. TO DO.
WHERE YOU ARE WHEN THE CPUC IS
IT YOU HAVE TO SIGN BUT THE TELL
SORRY?
IN THEM.
THE TWO WHERE THE BREAK COME OUT
AND HAVE DIFFERENT PEOPLE DO THE
MORE HAVE PEOPLE DO THEM WHO
HAVE.
A KNOWLEDGE THAT RELATES TO THE
OTHER GROUP GROUP BAY HAS NOT
ONLY TO RELEASE TO BE OR
WHATEVER BUT YOU NEED TO DEVELOP --
AT IT WELL INVOICE AVOIDING
CONFLICT AND ENCOURAGING
INTERDEPENDENCE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY.
IN NOT THAT QUITE LANGUAGE BUT
IS NOT YOUR LAST DISCUSSION BUT
THE ONE BEFORE THAT.
IN EVERY ORGANIZATION THAT'S
GOING TO BE -- SAFE.
THAT'S SO THEY NEED TO DO.
IT AM I AYE.
IF YOU DON'T MIND I USE THAT MY
NEXT PAPER.
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T HEARD REALLY
SAID LIKE THAT BUT THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE REGULATOR
AND THE REGULATE TV.
YOU DON'T NEED NEED TO DO IN
THIS ALL KINDS OF REGULATIONS
THERE'S REGULAR I'VE WATCHED A
LOT OF REGULATION THE MILITARY
THAT NO ONE WOULD CALL
REGULATION.
BUT THAT THEY DO CALL PROBLEM
SOLVING.
AND SO I IT'S I FOR THAT DAY I
GET ARE FOR RIGHT THERE AND
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO FROM THERE WHAT EVERYBODY
NEEDS.
TO FIND THAT THE TASK.
FIND THE ONES THAT THE MIX A
LITTLE BIT -- IF YOU GOT THE
RIGHT PLAYERS THAT'S ALWAYS A
PROBLEM ARM IN THEM -- WORRY
ABOUT WHAT WHETHER YOU GOT THREE
ORGANIZATIONS OR ONE
ORGANIZATION OR HALF AN ORGAN IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
BUT WORRY ABOUT PUTTING THOSE
TASKS INTO A MIX WHERE YOU HAVE --
ABILITY TO AGREE IT IN A SET OF
TAX EL AND THE DESIRE TO
INTEGRATE AMONG ALL OF THEM.
AND THAT'S I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THE CRUX OF THE PROBLEM.
IS BUT IF YOU DESIGN A CULTURE
WITH THE PUNITIVE ASPECT LIKE
THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED.
I I'VE SEEN IT DONE AND SO IS
PAUL I'M SURE YOU HAVE.
TO IT JUST GOES AWRY.
I AM VERY RAPIDLY YOU HAVE A OWN.
SURE AND THE I AGREE WITH THE
WHAT YOU SAID SO -- YEAH.
YEAH I I'M NOT I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE IF THAT WAS A SO YOU DON'T
WOULD THOUGH BUT I SAID
PREVIOUSLY BUT I THINK AT THE
LINES SO WITH THE WITH THIS
BEING THE WITH THE PRINCIPLES OF
WILL WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT.
DO NOT HAVE FEWER OF YOU DID
TERMS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE THE REGULATED AND
CITY AND THE THE REGULATOR OF
THE UTILITIES AND IF YOU SEE IN
THIS CASE -- A COOP KEEP GOING
BACK TO FUNCTIONS AND ROLES I
DON'T THINK IT'S A SINGLE ANSWER
FOR THE FOR THE AEGIS YOUR
SINGLE RELATIONSHIP.
OF A AYE AND ITO.
EIGHT BIG DOCTOR SHULMAN.
IN I A L..
I AGREE AND AND AND KIND OF
DISAGREE AT THE SAME TIME SO
THEY YOU KNOW THEY THEY THINK
THAT IN TERMS OF CULTURE AND AND
ADVOCATING FOR SAFETY.
AND ALL OF THOSE ELEMENTS.
EITHER WERE WE ARE IN AGREEMENT
BUT THEN THERE ARE ALSO DETAILS
OF HOW ORGANIZATIONS WORK AND
THERE'S PROCESS SEES AND THERE'S
METHODS RATE AND FORMAL ADVOCACY
IS ONE OF THEM RATE.
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO DO IT SO
WHATEVER YOU CALL IT WE CAN CALL
IT BEING AN INTERVENOR INSTEAD
OF ADVOCACY RAID BUT THERE ARE.
YOU THIS WAY IS THAT WE YOU KNOW
FORMAL RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE HOW
THE TO REGULATED AND CITIES AND
THE REGULATOR AND IS DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS WITHIN THE SORT OF
SAFETY PARADIGM.
AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE TO WE
SHOULDN'T HOW OF ALL PEOPLE
DOING ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND
FOR FILLING EVERY SINGLE
FUNCTION.
SO IF YOU HOW OF INSPECTOR WORK
FORCE RATE WHO'S GOING OUT THERE
AND DOING KIND OF BOOTS ON THE
GROUND INSPECTION OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S A CERTAIN
SKILL SET THEN THEY SHOULD HAVE
A CERTAIN RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE REGULAR WITH THE AND
CITY WHICH INFRASTRUCTURE THERE
INSPECTING RATED.
L. OF THE SHOULD OF YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO COORDINATE WITH THE HOME
RAISE ISSUES THAT THEY SEE IN
THE FEEL BE ABLE TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
IT YOU KNOW AND THEN.
IF THE YOU KNOW FIND VIOLATIONS
TO DOCUMENT THEM APPROPRIATELY
RATE.
THEN YOU HALL OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE FUNCTIONS INSIDE
OF AUDITING FUNCTIONS AND EITHER
YOU THE RAILS UNTIL WE YOU KNOW
HALL OF ABSOLUTE PERFECTION IN
THE SYSTEM.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THE PLACE AND THEY THINK
WE ALL KNOW THAT YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT THE TOOL THAT
YOU ALWAYS WANT TO GO TO AS YOUR
ONLY METHOD.
OF ASSURING SAFETY IT IS A TOOL
THAT NEEDS TO BE IN THE
REGULATORS TOOLBOX AND WHEN YOU
HEALTH STAFF.
WHO ARE IN THAT ENFORCEMENT
CAPACITY AND ARE DOING THE
INVESTIGATING AND A SAFETY
SHARON'S FUNCTION YOU KNOW THERE
MAKES SENSE TO HOBBES SOME MORE
ADVERSARIAL RELATIONSHIP AND
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF DISTANCE
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE IN THE%
MIDDLE OF AN INVESTIGATION AND
THE PENALTY PHASE THAT PROBABLY
ISN'T?
THE PLACE WHERE YOU WANT TO
HARLEM VERY CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
AND BE DOING.
YO COLLABORATIVE BRAINSTORMING
WITH THE AND CITY THAT YOU ARE
YOU KNOW ASSURING COMPLIANCE
OFTEN HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE FOR
SOMETHING THAT WENT WRONG RATE.
BUT IT'S WOULD WITH TALKING
ABOUT THINGS LIKE POLICY
DEVELOPMENTS.
AND YOU KNOW DEVELOPING L.
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESSING THE
WILDFIRE CHALLENGE YES A THINK
BY IN THAT ONTEXT IS VERY
APPROPRIATE SO HALL OF OPEN
COMMUNICATION.
AND IS YOUR BILL STUB WAS CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS OF WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND BRING IN
DIFFERENT EXPERTS OF BOUNCE
IDEAS RATE AND SO TO ME WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SAFETY
FUNCTION AT YOU GET IN AND THE
ROLE OF THE REGULATOR IT ISN'T
JUST ONE THING.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BREAK IT DOWN
IN SCHOOL THESE DIFFERENT AREAS
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE.
IN WHICH CASE YOU DEL AND SEEING
FOR YOU KNOW SAFETY CULTURE
WITHIN THE P. YOU SEE YOU KNOW
THERE ARE ALSO WITH GLEE.
YOU KNOW YOU THE EXPECTATIONS
FOR NEW STAFF WHO PERFORM.
AUDITS OF THE UTILITY SYSTEM FOR
SAFETY AND SOMEBODY WHO WORKS IN
THE WATER DIVISION THAT JUST
DOESN'T RATE MAKING FOR WATER
RATES LIKE THEY'RE GONNA HAVDE
YOU THOSE YES SAFETY SHOULD BE
ON TOP OF EVERYBODY'S MIND.
BUT WHAT WE WANT THOSE PEOPLE TO
DO IS VERY DIFFERENT RATE AND I
AND SO I ALSO MONTHLY.
DO YOU THINK THAT AT LEAST WHERE
I A CANDLE SET A DATE I FIND IT
USEFUL TO BREAK THIS QUESTION
DOWN A LITTLE BIT MORE AND NOT
TALK ABOUT IT JUST AS A SORT OF
AGENCY ON COMPANY LEVEL.
WITH THE VERY.
VERY GOOD -- YOU KEEP GETTING
BACK TO THE THE ISSUE OF THE YOU
KNOW SEPARATING SAFETY OUT OF
THE FEW SEE INTO A SEPARATE.
ENTITY OF SOME TYPE OR AGENCY
HOW -- IF THERE WERE.
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THAT
AGENCY TO THE P. UC OR TWO I AM
STRUGGLING WITH HOW THAT WOULD
WORK.
AND WHETHER THEY WOULD BE
MARGINALIZED IN SOME WAY OR OR
IGNORED OR JUST WOULDN'T BE.
WOULDN'T FIT INTO THE THE KIND
OF THE THE CONVERSATION I GUESS
WITHIN THE PC AND AND MAYBE
THAT'S THE BENEFIT WITH HAVING
OSAGE PART OF THE ORGANIZATION
TODAY.
VERSUS HAVING A SEPARATE AGENCY
AND AND I THINK READY MADE VERY
GOOD POINTS ABOUT.
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO CREATE A
DIFFERENT EDGE AS A SEPARATE
AGENCY WITH THIS OR A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT HOWEVER WOULD BE DONE
IT WOULD BE A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING?
AND THEN WHERE DO YOU DRAW THE
LINES WITHIN THAT SO IT DID
SOMETHING TO HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
AND LEFT IN MAYBE DIRECTOR IF
YOU WANNA GO FIRST AND THEN
[inaudible] FOR A THE THIRD I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO FUNCTIONS AGAIN
RATE ALONG WHICH FUNCTIONS WE
TALKING ABOUT ALL SAFETY
FUNCTIONS OF YOU THOUGH OR A
SUBSET OF THE YOU KNOW I THINK
IF YOU WANTED TO JUST SPIN OFF
ADVOCACY FORMAL ADVOCACY.
HOME KIND OF HOW WE HOW OF WITH
THE ELVES.
GO WITH THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE LAURIE ALL EITHER THAT'S
ONE MODEL BUT THAT'S A VERY SO
THAT'S ONE VERY SPECIFIC
FUNCTION FORMAL ADVOCACY RATE.
IF YOU WERE IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TAKING YOU KNOW LET'S SAY
ALMOST EVERYTHING OUT OF THE P.
YOU SEE FROM POLICY MAKING ROLE
WE THROW TO ENFORCEMENT BOOTS ON
THE GROUND ADVOCACY YOU KNOW AND
CREATING A NEW AGENCY THAT DOES
ALL OF THE SAFETY FUNCTIONS.
L. YOU KNOW THERE IS YOU KNOW
YOU CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION
AROUND THAT BUT THERE'S YOU KNOW
EVERY TIME I SORT OF PLAY AROUND
WITH THIS YOU STILL END UP WITH.
THE COMMISSION MEETING TO
PERFORM A CERTAIN SAFETY
FUNCTION AND MEETING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S FUNCTION IS
STAFFED SO.
IT YOU KNOW EVEN IF YOU SEE ALL
OF THE ENFORCEMENT OUT OVER THE
P. YOU SEE RATE LEGISLATORS THAT
THERE'S AN EXAMPLE IN U. HAUL
THE SEPARATE WORK FOR SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND THE FOR AN AGENCY IN
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T REALLY MATTER
TO DOES INSPECTIONS ON ITS.
IN THE SIXTIES FRIENDS FUNCTION
ONCE WE FIND AN ISSUE THE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT IF YOU
SAY TO THREATEN FINE JUDICATA
SOMEHOW RATE.
IT ALSO WITH THE COMES BACK TO
THE P. U. C. L. I END.
YOU -- TO IN ORDER TO ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING WITH US
YOU KNOW THE P. YOU SEE STILL
NEEDS TO HALL OF ABILITY.
TO ACT ON IT SO L. U. YOU STILL
SORT OF NEEDS IS FULL OF LIGHT --
THAT ASPECT OF IT AND THEN YOU
CAME OVER END UP WITH THE SAME
PROBLEM OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
BITE SEEKING SAFETY OUT OF THE
P. YOU SEE YOU SENDING THE
MESSAGE TO THE AGENCY THAT THIS
IS NO LONGER YOUR PRIMARY
FUNCTION THAT WE HELPING
SOMEBODY ELSE WAS GOING. TO BE
DOING THIS JOB.
BUT THEN YET WHEN THE ISSUE COM
DID DID THE CHICKEN COMES T
RULES THAT THE P. YOU SEE YOU
WANT THE PC TO PRAY OR IT'S A
SAFETY BUT YOU JUST DE FUNDED.
THE FUNCTION OF THE PC SO YOU
KNOW EIGHT THINK YOU KIND OF RUN
ON THE RUN INTO THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES JUST PRACTICALLY SPEAKING.
BUT AGAIN IT I THINK IF YOU'RE
JUST FOCUSING ON THE PUBLIC
ADVISORS OFFICE I WOULD SAY A
SLUR ON THE THE ON THE THE
OFFICE OF SAFETY ADVOCATES.
HELLO IN THE IDEAL -- OF YOU
KNOW SHOULD IT REPORTS BASICALLY
THROUGH THE P. UC'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OR SHOULD IT GET SORT
OF SPUN OUT.
ALL I WOULD SAY THAT IN TERMS OF
THE FORMAL ADVOCACY IN
ADVOCATING A PROCEEDINGS.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT DOESN'T
REALLY MATTER WHERE THEY LIVE
WELL AS LONG AS THEY'RE YOU KNOW
ALLOWED TO INTERVENE.
IN PROCEEDINGS AND BE YEAR OLD
SORT OF FREE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPINIONS WHICHEVER WAY THEY WANT
WHICH I HAVE NOT HEARD OF THAT
EVER OF THAT BEING AN ISSUE.
YOU KNOW I'VE NOT HEARD THAT
REYES THAT YOU POINT THAT THE
ISSUE RIGHT NOW WITH -- WITH
STAYS IN THE FIELD AT THE CON
ADVOCATE FOR SAFETY BECAUSE OF
THE VIEW ISN'T WELCOME BECAUSE
THE REPORTS TO THE PC STRUCTURE.
ALL UNITS NOT WITH THE ISSUE A
TRYING TO SAW WOULD SAY THAT
INDEPENDENCE IS THE SOLUTION BUT
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THE
PRIMARY PROBLEM.
I THINK THE ISSUE WITH YOU KNOW
THE HOME ADVOCATING FOR SAFETY
WITHIN THE PC AND SORT OF
PROMOTING THE SAFETY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM WHILE BEING AN OUTSIDE
AND CITY THAT DOESN'T REPORT TO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
YOU KNOW YOU CREATE THIS WAY FOR
CREATION OF RESPONSIBILITY THAT
YOU KNOW IF THEY RECOMMEND
CERTAIN MEASURES FOR THE PC TO
TAKE.
IN THE PC THAN THE HOUSE TWO
OPTIONS RIGHT THE EITHER JUST
DOES EXACTLY WHAT THE ALWAYS SAY
SAYS.
AND THEN THINGS STILL GO BAD THE
PC WILL GOAL WHAT.
WAS THEY TOLD US DO IT WILL WIN
DOING WHATEVER WE BEING TOLD SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S THEIR FAULT.
OR THEY DECIDE TO SORT OF ACT
DIFFERENTLY FROM WHAT WAS SAY IS
SUGGESTING.
RATE BUT THEN YOUR AGAIN YOUR
SEVERAL WHO WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE ISSUES WHEN YOU WANT TO
KNOW LIKE WHAT IS THE AGENCY
DOING AND WHO DO YOU POINTS WAS
BEING REALLY RESPONSIBLE YOU THE
KIND OF DON'T KNOW OLD KIND OF
WHERE TO GO.
SO YOU THINK. ZERO ALSO THE YOU
CAN MAKE IT WORK BOTH WAYS BUT I
WOULD KIND OF KEEP GOING BACK TO
WHICH FUNCTIONS WITH TALKING
ABOUT BEING OUTSIDE OF THE
COMMISSION AND WHAT PROBLEM DO
WE REALLY THINK THAT THAT.
SORT OF SOULS.
OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU I CAN
THINK OF A ONE ONE AWARD YEAH
OKAY.
QUICKLY FIND WHAT ONE ONE MODEL
THAT MIGHT WORK.
AN INDEPENDENT SAFETY A UTILITY
SAFETY BOARD.
OR ADVISORY BOARD WHATEVER YOU
WANNA CALL IT THAT HAS
RECOGNIZED EXPERTS SINCE IN
SAFETY AND A STAFF.
THAT TAKES OVER THE RESEARCH AND
ANALYSIS FUNCTIONS LOOKS AT THE
LITERATURE TRANSLATES INTO
REGULATORY FRAMES OF REFERENCE
THAT ARE USEFUL.
AND ADDS ACCIDENT INVESTIGATIONS
THAT THE UC MIGHT THINK ARTS OR
THE PUBLIC THINKS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT THEY WOULD DO.
HIRE PEOPLE IF NECESSARY IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN STAFF TO DO
IT THE ACTION INVESTIGATIONS AND
THAT.
THEY WOULD REPORT THESE THINGS --
AND THEY WOULD MAKE AT TIMES.
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR POLICY TO
THE PC.
I SEE TO BENEFITS OF THIS ONE IS
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BURDEN THE PC
WITH ADDING YET ANOTHER FUNCTION
WHICH IT'S NOT DOING VERY WELL
NOW AND RESEARCH AND THEY COULD
DO IT SEPARATELY AND HAVE A LOT
OF PRESTIGE ABOUT DOING THAT.
FUNCTION AT THEIR LEVEL OF SKILL.
AND THE THE POLICY ADVICE THEY
GIVE TO THE PC FOR REGULATIONS
OR WHATEVER OTHER POLICIES.
WOULD HAVE SOME WEIGHT.
AND WHAT I SEE IS THIS WOULD
GIVE A LOT OF POLITICAL COVER.
TO THE PC WHICH IS CURRENTLY
DOESN'T HAVE NOW BECAUSE WILL
DON'T THINK IT HAS ANY
COMPETENCE NECESSARILY WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
ITS INVOLVEMENT.
IT WOULD GIVE POLITICAL AND
PUBLIC PRESTIGE.
IF THE P. YOU SEE DECIDE OKAY ON
THE BASIS OF THE RECOMMENDATION
OF THIS ADVISORY BOARD WE HAVE
DECIDED TO ADOPT THIS.
PARTICULAR.
RULE OR REGULATION OR WHATEVER --
AND I THINK THAT THAT THAT'S
POSSIBLE I COULD SEE THAT
HAPPENING WITHOUT DEGRADING THE
OTHER FUNCTIONS OF THE UC.
AND ACTUALLY ADDING SOMETHING TO
A PRECARIOUS.
POLITICAL SITUATION THEY
CURRENTLY FIND THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IN
[inaudible]
AND THIS ISN'T BEEN -- VERY
INFORMATIVE.
FIVE REALLY GRATEFUL. FOR FOR
THE CONVERSATION I'VE LEARNED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT TODAY AND I
THINK EVERYONE HAS THOSE
WATCHING ON THE CAMERAS AND
ELSEWHERE HAVE IS IS WELL -- WE
BEST KIND OF DIFFICULT QUESTIONS
TODAY AND I THINK THAT'S KIND OF
OUR JOB TO DO THAT AND IF TRYING
TO GET TO IT I READ THE STRIKE
FORCES REPORT IN THE CPUC
PROCESS.
QUESTIONS IT RAISES AS A CALL TO
ACTION FOR THIS LEGISLATURE OF
THE SENATE IS ALREADY TAKING
ACTIVE STEPS THROUGH THE
FORMATION OF A SELECT COMMITTEE
TO EXAMINE THE MANY PIECES OF
THE LARGER ISSUE OF SAFETY
ACROSS.
THE STATE'S UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND IN MANY
WAYS.
HAS BEEN AHEAD OF OTHER UTILITY
COMMISSIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN THE WAY THAT IT'S TRYING TO
ADDRESS SAFETY OVERSIGHT IN THE
AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT.
READING MANY YOUR QUESTION IF
THOSE EFFORTS ARE ENOUGH.
IF THE PROCESS IS IN PLACE AT
THE CPUC MAKE FORWARD PROGRESS
ON SAFETY DIFFICULT.
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE AND SO IS
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
MESSAGE THE CQC IS AT THE CENTER
OF ALL THIS AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T LOSE
SIGHT.
OF THEM AND IN THE UPCOMING
DISCUSSIONS AS WE GO FORWARD NO
AGENCY -- A NOT EVEN THE PC IS
AN ISLAND AS WE ALL KNOW AND WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THAT
WE'VE A TO OUR ROUTE JOB IS THE
RESPONSIBLE OVERSEERS OF OF
THEIR ACTIONS AND THAT -- WE
REPRESENT AS WE ALL DO.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND DO
IT AS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR FOR
BEING HERE AND WHILE YOU'RE
THERE ARE JUST ONE OPEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANY PUBLIC --
COMMENTS IF ANYONE IS HERE TO
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS.
SEEN NO.
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATED VERY
INFORMATIVE BERINGER